Neues Betriebssystem.
Auf deinem Telefon.
Auf meinem Telefon. Und die geblendeten Massen da draußen.
Wahnsinn, endlich wieder die Tim-Begeisterung, die uns so gefehlt hat.
Ja, ich meine, wir befinden uns ja hier in einem Live-Podcast. Da gibt es ja zum Beispiel solche Herausforderungen, wie wir erfassen Show-Notes im Web-Kollaborativ. Oder wir bearbeiten dann vielleicht auch mal die Aufzeichnung später und ergänzen diese Show-Notes. Also das ist ja, würde ich sagen, so eine dieser Dinge, wo man so im Web an so einem überschaubaren Datenmodell arbeiten möchte, so ein bisschen Web-Funktionalität. So ich spiele auch noch was ab und höre zu. Und dann erzeugt man irgendwie Daten und irgendwann will man die auch mal zurücksinken, aber es ist jetzt nicht unbedingt so mega zeitkritisch, wann das jetzt genau geschieht.
Stell dir vor, du hörst gerade den Podcast und ich habe aber einen Podcast-Player und ich möchte kommentieren zu irgendeinem Stelle. Also ich habe einen Podcast-Player, dem mir das erlaubt. Und ich bin halt gerade unterwegs, wo ich kein Netz habe. Und dann kann ich die Notiz schnell machen und die wird dann als Kommentar auf der Live-Seite gezeigt, wenn ich halt wieder online bin.
Wenn das dann so endlich mal in das Backend eingeflossen ist, wo es dann so das Hoodie-Plugin irgendwie Submit-Podcast-Comment installiert hat. Ja, das war schon mal ganz gute Kopfreise an der Stelle.
Erzähl doch mal was über Offline First. Ihr macht da jetzt so eine Bewegung.
Genau, also wir haben das, was du gerade so beschrieben hast, das haben wir mal unter offlinefirst.org zusammengefasst. Da haben wir uns überlegt, wir tun jetzt mal, ist der Hoodie schon fertig komplett und das ist ja auch schon so ziemlich.
Die Karte da oben erinnert mich ein bisschen daran, wo ich in Italien war. Das war auch so Offline First.
Also stell dir vor, ich habe jetzt so eine Funktion, also sowas, was genauso funktioniert und ich habe so eine App, die genau das macht, die singt Sachen hin und her, wenn ich mal online bin. Wenn ich jetzt aber mal so eine App entwerfen möchte, so von der Benutzeroberfläche her, dann tun sich neue Fragen auf und ich ziehe das jetzt mal von IMAP auf. IMAP hat das Datenmodell, ich habe einzelne Datenobjekte, die sind zeitlich sortiert, die ja lokale angekommen Timestamp ist, wonach ich sortiere und die ändern sich nie und die sind in der Liste darstellbar und wenn was Neues ist, dann kommt es halt oben in die Liste rein, wird halt bold gemacht, so lange, weil ich mal angeguckt habe, wird es dann an, also wird dann nicht mehr fett gedruckt. Genau. Und genauso andersrum, im Prinzip so eine Queue, so eine Liste, die halt andersrum dann alles abbastelt, wenn ich halt online bin und Sachen auf den Server schieben muss. Jetzt gibt es aber Anwendungen, die andere Datenstrukturen haben, zum Beispiel, ich habe so einen Chatraum zum Beispiel oder eine kollaborative Bildbearbeitungssoftware oder so. Und dann ergeben sich, was ist das, ich tue neue Daten oben auf die Liste, äquivalent für eine Bildbearbeitung. So. Und da haben wir uns gedacht, es gibt ja dieses Feld, dieses User, nein, Human-Computer-Interaction oder dieses, wie heißt das auf Deutsch, die Wissenschaft der Benutzerführung oder Benutzer-Oberflüge.
User-Interaction-Design.
Ja, genau dieses.
Nichts in unserer Welt heißt auf Deutsch.
Also Human-Computer-Interaction, das gibt es ja auch schon seit den 70ern, 80ern. Und dann dachten wir, gehen wir einfach in den Bibliothek und nehmen uns den Band raus, der halt Offline-Patterns erklärt und dann lernen wir da halt über alles, um schreiben, das sind die Hoodie-Doku-Reihen. Dann stellt sich halt raus, das gibt es nicht. Da gibt es keine...
Jetzt leere gegriffen.
Genau, da ist einfach nichts. Und da haben wir gedacht, das müsste es mal geben. Das hat jetzt mit Hoodie, also wir brauchen das für Hoodie, aber das hat mit uns nicht zwingend nur zu tun. Es gibt auch andere Leute, die sich darüber Gedanken machen und die könnten davon auch profitieren. Und dann haben wir gedacht, wir machen da mal so eine Bewegung raus und wir haben nicht so viel Zeit, leider, wie wir gerne hätten. Deswegen gibt es jetzt diese Webseite und GitHub-Projekt, wo dann über verschiedene Issues diskutiert wird und gesammelt wird. Ich würde hoffen, dass wir mal echte Forscher finden oder irgendjemanden finden, der Forscher bezahlen kann, dass man das mal so ein bisschen aufräumt. Oder wenn wir mal irgendwann Zeit dafür haben, machen wir da auch weiter. Im Moment ist das so ein bisschen ein Sammelbecken für diese ganzen Technologien, die das können, die da die Entwicklungen gibt. Es gibt im Webbereich so, dass die Browser ein bisschen mehr können, dass man so eine Sachen schöner bauen kann. Aber auch, wie könnte man jetzt zum Beispiel, das ist normal, also Desktop-Anwendung kriegt man die Diskette als Speichersymbol. Was ist so ein Äquivalent für, ich schicke jetzt meinen Tweet ab, aber der ist jetzt geschickt, aber noch nicht geschickt. Oder ich habe den jetzt geschickt, aber der ist auch schon auf dem Server. Wie kann ich das zum Beispiel erklären? Oder in einem User-Interface klar machen?
Ich hoffe, euch fällt da was Besseres ein als Diskette für Speichern.
Genau, aber solche Diskussionen werden da jetzt gerade mal ausgetragen und geguckt.
So eine Pause-Taste wäre doch nicht schlecht. Und dann ist der Draht entweder angeschlossen oder nicht? Würde zur Diskette passen.
Das erzeugt mich jetzt nicht so ganz, Roddy.
Mist.
Der Schock sitzt tief.
Ja Mensch.
Roddy, offline-first. Ich bin ja ein großer offline-Freund. Echt, und da gibt es überhaupt keine akademischen Tätigkeiten zu?
Das ist, da sind wir auch so, wir sagen das jetzt einfach und hoffen auf diesen Standard-Nord-Reflex. Natürlich gibt es da was. Ich weiß das ganz genau, dass uns die Leute es endlich mal sagen. Das ist bisher nicht passiert, aber wenn ihr das besser wisst, also bitte sagt uns das. Wenn es da aus den 80ern, 90ern oder in den letzten Jahrzehnten auch irgendwelche Forschungen zu gibt oder auch schöne Beispiele, bitte gibt uns das. Wir müssen das wissen. Der Chat hatte dazu schon eine Vorlesung.
Der Chat weiß ja alles, ne? Also wahrscheinlich so chatfirst.org wäre vielleicht auch nochmal ganz angemessen.
Da gibt's einen ganz schönen, also nicht dringend Chat, aber so Messaging, da gibt's ein schönes Problem. Du kennst das von iMessage. Also überhaupt, wenn du so verteiltes System machst und Messaging machst, wo man mal offline sein kann, da kennst du ja das, dass man, wenn du schickst mir eine Nachricht und dann kommt die zweite, die mir steht, das kommt vor der ersten an. Oder wenn wir einen Gruppenchat mit Jens haben, weil er hier gerade sitzt, dann kommt die Antwort von Jens manchmal schon, bevor deine Frage bei mir ankommt. So, weil Netzwerke so funktionieren. Dann gibt's halt auch wieder zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder ich sortiere das so, wie das bei mir angekommen ist, oder ich sortiere das nach dem Timestamp der abgesendeten Zeiten. Dann weiß ich das, wenn ich jetzt auf dem Telefon unterwegs bin und wir schon ein paar Nachrichten weitersehen, kann sein, dass außerhalb des Sichtbereichs eine neue Nachricht kommt. Wenn ich halt die Logik erhalten möchte, ein Message macht es so und dann gibt es andere Anwendungen, die machen das Neueste immer nach unten. Und da weiß man dann immer nicht ganz genau, wie die Reihenfolge dann mal gemein sein sollte. Aber beides hat Vor- und Nachteile, weil entweder weiß ich nicht, dass dann eine Nachricht gekommen ist, oder ich sehe die in einem falschen Kontext. Und da gibt es keine schöne Lösung für, das muss man halt irgendwie rumtricksen. Aber so eine Überlegung finden wir da halt ganz spannend.
Ich wäre schon mal froh, wenn sich mal so klare Usage-Patterns herausbilden würden, ob Chats nun von oben nach unten oder von unten nach oben zu sehen sind. So dieses Timeline-Konzept hat irgendwie alles durcheinander gebracht. Also früher war der Chat natürlich, hat man immer unten eingetippt und es scrollte nach oben weg. Das war einfach so. Und so die Twitter-Timeline spätestens hat das irgendwie alles auf den Kopf gestellt. Und am geilsten finde ich dann immer die Programme, das hat, glaube ich, mittlerweile lassen sie es alle sein, aber so die ersten Twitter-Clines waren dann so, die Timeline geht es halt von unten nach oben, aber deine Direct-Messages, die sind dann so wie ein Chat von oben nach unten. Also das ist wirklich, das geht nun wirklich überhaupt nicht. Und ich weiß gar nicht, was jetzt irgendwie gewonnen hat, aber ich glaube, so dieses, wenn man schon so eine Timeline hat, dann muss man dieses Modell auch irgendwie komplett bis zum Ende durchtragen. Ja, so, ach Mensch, ja, da gibt es dann noch so viel zu holen. Jetzt müssen wir dir, glaube ich, aber erst mal eine kleine Pause gönnen. Was denn sonst noch so passiert? Wollen wir nicht erstmal hier...
Ein bisschen über Max reden.
Ihr kichert ja da auch schon die ganze Zeit wie so kleine Jungs. Was ist denn da so toll bei euch?
Na, der Roddy hat ja irgendwie sein, dieses OS X, dieses Beta, hat sich der Roddy irgendwie verkackt. Warum auch immer, muss der jetzt das Ganze nochmal von vorn installieren, damit er das neueste Beta installieren kann.
Also ich hatte, ich war etwas gewagt und hab's einfach auf Deutsch installiert.
Wie auf Deutsch installiert? Naja, Deutsch als Hauptsprache.
Und der aus irgendeinem Grund hat es den Software-Updater komplett durcheinander gebracht, weswegen der immer wieder versucht hat, das gleiche Update zu laden und zu installieren.
Du meinst, es lag echt auf der Sprache?
Ja, und jetzt hab ich auf Englisch umgestellt und jetzt ging's.
Bleeding Edge gibt's nicht auf Deutsch.
Aber meiner wollte auch zwei, dreimal nicht booten und kam mit Colonel Panic und so und dann ging's dann aber irgendwann. Das hatte ich beim letzten Update auch schon. Also irgendwas ist da gerade voodoo-mäßig komisch. Ist nicht so klar.
Naja gut, das ist halt eine Beta.
Aber jetzt haben sie ja auch alle drauf losgelassen.
Also sich bei einer Beta darüber zu beklagen, dass sie ganz schön Beta ist, finde ich irgendwie ganz schön Beta.
Also Colonel Panic muss jetzt nicht unbedingt sein.
Das ist aber ganz schön Beta.
Das ist ganz schön Alpha.
Also da habe ich schon schlimmere Betas erlebt, ganz ehrlich.
Naja, wenn ich nicht mehr booten kann und nicht mehr reinkomme in meinen Rechner, dann finde ich schon mal ein bisschen scary. Aber geht ja jetzt. Nach einer Weile ging's ja. Dann haben wir gerade gekichert und Facepalms gegenseitig zugeschmissen fast, oder? Die haben den Swift-Operator. Wie heißt der eigentlich, der Operator?
Also es gibt den Operator für eine Range von bis so. Und es gibt einen von bis exklusive und es gibt einen von bis inklusive. Der von bis exklusive sind zwei Punkte und der von bis inklusive waren drei Punkte und sind jetzt zwei Punkte und ein kleiner Zeichen.
Das ist mal voll scheiße. Was? Haben sie jetzt mal geändert, schnell, seit letztem Mal.
Na das Problem war ja, dass Robi das genau andersrum hatte und sich alle Robi-Leute beschwert haben, dass das nicht ganz passt. Und dann hat klar wurde...
Die hatten die drei Punkte, das war exklusive. Ne, wie war das hier rum?
Scheiße. Zwei Punkte exklusive, drei Punkte inklusive war es.
Genau, aber es gab wohl andere, die dagegen waren. Und dann konnte man, wenn man es ganz logisch betrachtet, auch irgendwie...
Punkt, Punkt, kleiner?
Also ich hoffe, sie rudern nochmal zurück.
Ja, es ist halt ein bisschen in Flux.
Naja, aber ich meine, jetzt ist der richtige Zeitpunkt, um noch Sachen zu fixen. Aber ich finde, das reduced gar nicht, sondern das kippt sich doch aufs Scheiß.
Naja, sagen wir mal so, wenn man den Code liest, sieht man natürlich schneller, ob es zwei oder drei Punkte sind. Also das sehe ich schon als Vorteil. Ob jetzt Punkt, Punkt, kleiner wirklich so schön anzuschauen ist, darüber kann man noch mal reden.
Ja, warum kein Emoji?
Backhand with middle finger extended.
Hat es nicht Operator overloading?
Ja, du, nee, du kannst, du kannst, es gibt Operator overloading, aber es gibt irgendwie nur ein halbes Dutzend oder Dutzend Zeichen, die du als Operatoren überladen kannst. Du kannst allerdings natürlich Funktionen machen, die einen Emoji-Namen haben. Also du kannst funk, wie hieß das? Backhand mit middle finger extended, Klammer auf Klammer zu und das ist dann deine middle finger Funktion. Also das geht.
Das ist das neue Unicode-Zeichen für Fakio.
Ist eigentlich schon fast lyrische Umschreibung.
Ich fand diese Metadebatte, die irgendwie bei Gruber tobte, ob Apple denn dieses Zeichen nun aufnehmen wird oder nicht.
Ja, das ist aber typisch Gruber, dass solche Metadebatten gerade bei ihm aufschlagen irgendwie, oder?
Der Chat korrigiert uns gerade, das Punkt, Punkt, kleiner ist das Exklusive und das Punkt, Punkt, Punkt ist das Inklusive. Das macht dann noch...
Ja, kleiner, klar. Ohne dass, was da hinter steht, macht auch Sinn.
Das ist verständlich, aber nicht schön.
Also, das ist einfach das Problem, wenn du so eine Programmiersprache so auf so Satzzeichen anfickst.
Du hast letztes Mal meinen Rant, fandest du komplett daneben, weil ich gesagt habe, Operator Overloading ist einfach kacke. Und jetzt sehen wir hier, was dabei rumkommt.
Nein, nein, die Frage ist ja, was sind denn diese Operatoren? Also, man kann sie ja auch voll ausschreiben. Man hätte ja auch ganze Worte benutzen können. Muss ja nicht immer Ausrufezeichen sein, wenn man auch Not schreiben könnte. Und das ist durchaus...
Ja, wenn schon wieder so eine komische Konstruktion kommt, dann nehme ich ja doch lieber wieder NS-Make-Range oder sowas.
Ja, also, ich fand das mit dem Emoji jetzt gar keinen schlechten Vorschlag, weil da gibt es ja dann irgendwie auch echt eine ganze Menge... Ist nicht gerade so eine Programmiersprache rausgekommen, die komplett nur auf Emoji basiert?
Emoji-Overloading oder was?
Ja, wo alles irgendwie in Emoji ist.
Nee, es gibt jetzt wohl so ein soziales Netzwerk, wo dein Username als Emoji ist.
Ach so, genau, ein Social-Netzwerk, weil jetzt habe ich das total durcheinander...
Programmiersprache gibt es leider, verdanken wir nicht.
Doch, gibt es.
Also du könntest natürlich Whitespace nur in Emoji schreiben, ne?
Zum Beispiel.
So Timme, weil du jetzt keinen O-Saft mehr hast, muss ich jetzt Mathe trinken. Ich kann doch ja nicht einschlafen.
Ja.
Was war ich, die vier?
Emojinal heißt die Sprache.
Ne, doch. Drei warst du.
Emojinal, ja genau, ich bringe das mal hier on screen. Das war der falsche. Emojinal Programming ja tippt Ja, das ist eine Fanta. Die hatte ich eigentlich hier für unseren Gast gebracht, aber der hat sich dann schon selber eingedeckt. Du darfst es auch trinken, Dennis. Du darfst hier eigentlich fast alles. Aber du vaderst übrigens auch rechts rum. Also hat sich nicht viel getan hier.
Rechts drehen und links drehen, das ist eine Vaderung.
Du kannst auch komplett ein Emoji programmieren. Das ist auch sehr hübsch. Es sind auf jeden Fall schön viele Operatoren, die du dann alle überladen kannst. Ja, dann kannst du dann halt so mit dem Fakiu-Zeichen auch wirklich Programmiersprachen-Konstrukte aufrufen.
Das Fakiu-Zeichen ist doch gar kein Emoji, oder?
Nee, das ist richtig so ein Unicode. Ich schätze mal, hier ist nur Emoji erlaubt. Nee, hier ist aber auch so ein Fakiu drin.
Guck, da.
Fak-up und Fak-down gibt es hier sogar. True and false.
Fak-down?
Was ist das nicht? Thumbs up?
Naja, so Finger nach oben und Finger nach unten.
Ja, aber nicht Mittelfinger.
Das ist dann false. Das ist dann Mittelfinger.
Ich sehe das von hier nicht.
Doch, doch. Das sieht schon sehr nach Mittelfinger aus. Ja, das sieht das aber gerade nicht so viel größer. Naja, ist ja nicht so wild. Ich wollte jetzt auch nicht wirklich unter Emo-Gene poämieren. Das macht mich nur emo. Genau, das wäre auch mal schön. Emo, die Poemiersprache für so komplett pessimistische...
Es gibt nur false und null.
Lebensverneinende.
Null ist sozusagen das Super-Objekt von allem. Alles leitet sich aus dem Nichts ab und wird zu nichts.
Und die Bedingungen treffen immerzu, wenn es nicht gesetzt ist. Denn die folgt das immer an Null.
Genau, alle Funktionen müssen mit Fehlern enden. Da lässt sich vielleicht noch was draus drehen.
Da gibt es auch demnächst ein Buch bei Nostage, If Hemingway Wrote JavaScript. Ich glaube, da ist so etwas Ähnliches über Kierkegaard und seine Programmierung dann da drin.
Das ist der Angus Crawl. Der hat auf den diversen JavaScript-Konferenzen schon einen entsprechenden Talk gehalten. Und hat dann quasi JavaScript-Code geschrieben, der den jeweiligen klassischen Autoren zehn Stück jeweils nachempfunden ist. Und es ist zum Schießen.
Aha, verstehe.
Shakespeare-Code.
Also JavaScript-Code im Shakespeare-Style.
Genau, genau.
Aha.
Das heißt, da muss man nicht nur programmieren können, sondern auch noch alle Bücher gelesen haben, wenn man das witzig finden soll.
Aber haben wir ja alle.
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Also bei mir ist sowohl die JavaScript-Erfahrung als auch die Buchkenntnis sehr eingeschränkt vorhanden.
Ich weiß nicht, wer Roberto Bolanjo ist. Ja, dann habe ich wenigstens mal den Namen gehört.
Das ist auch tatsächlich die Alze, der mir nichts sagt.
Das ist trotzdem lustig. Ich paste mal den Videolink noch ins Chat. In den Chat, Entschuldigung.
Den Videolink, wo das vorgestellt wird.
Genau, es gibt so einen JSConf-Talk, wo er das gemacht hat.
Den schauen wir jetzt mal nicht komplett an.
Der Herr ist Brite und unheimlich lustig. Also, das ist schon ordentlich lustig.
Apropos Brite und ordentlich lustig.
Ach. Du Sau.
Der kommt hier reingelaufen und erzählt uns, dass er irgendwie gerade bei Monty Python war. Hast du da mal bitte mal...
Ja, die haben sich gedacht, wir machen mal einen auf Rolling Stones und spielen noch einen.
Du warst wirklich da.
Die verbleibenden Pythons haben jetzt so eine Live-Theatershow in London am Start, die gerade spielt. Und ich war dann bei der Aufführung mit dabei.
Waren nicht diese Tickets irgendwie nach 2,5 Millisekunden vergriffen?
Ja, das habe ich trotzdem geschafft, weil ich da mit guten F5-Finger saß.
Du hast ja eine Applikation vorher geschrieben. Gibt es auch so.
Jahrelange WWDC-Erfachung.
Ja, gar nicht so unverkehrt.
Kongress, sage ich nur.
Es gab so drei Seiten, wo man Tickets kaufen konnte. Und da hatte ich alle parallel mit verschiedenen Rechnern, über verschiedene Internetleitungen und alles. Und als die dann ausverkauft war, haben sie gesagt, wir machen noch 10 Shows. Dann war ich so ein bisschen, aha.
Aber du warst auf der ersten.
Ich habe dann noch die erste mitgemacht. Und das war schon sehr toll.
Und dann auch in der ersten Reihe?
Tatsächlich nur ganz außen. Also nicht vorne direkt, sondern wir hatten von oben rechts über die Schulter quasi. Aber wir hatten sehr gute Plätze.
Und?
Es war fantastisch, aber ich bin halt auch großer Fan. Ich kann das jetzt nicht anders erklären. Es war unheimlich schön, die ganzen Sachen mal live zu sehen. Es war sehr schön zu sehen, dass der Humor noch funktioniert. Die haben halt nur alte Sachen gemacht, die aber so ein bisschen neu interpretiert teilweise. Zum Beispiel? Keine Ahnung, die... Die haben den Cheese Shop und Parrot Sketch hintereinander gemacht quasi, als Medley. Wo er immer nach dem Käse fragt und den hat er dann nicht. Wensleydale?
Nope.
Und so weiter.
Wensleydale, das war jetzt, aber das waren die anderen, ne?
John Cleese kommt in den Teeshop und versucht Käse zu kaufen. Und der verkaufte dann so, nee, hast gar nicht da, ist ausverkauft, gibt's nicht. Und dann geht der Fliessen in den Parrot Sketch über, weil der auch mit John Cleese und Michael Palin ist. Verstehe. Und dann gab es so eine Tanzgruppe mit dabei, die halt die verschiedenen Songs, die ist dann auch da präsentiert worden, sind halt auch noch interpretiert halt. Das war auch sehr schön.
Läuft's?
Es gab die Terry Gilliam-Animationen auch.
Aber sind jetzt auch nur noch, es ist ja noch einer schon von ein paar Jahren, das heißt tatsächlich schon zwei.
Einer. Leben noch.
5 von 6.
One Down, Five To Go heißt der Slogan.
Also Graham Chapman ist schon lange tot.
Der, der der Brian war.
Genau.
Das nicht von ein paar Jahren, noch einer?
Ne, die sind noch, zumindest waren die jetzt alle da.
Erst mal die Beatles, bevor sie uns Monty Python auch noch nehmen.
Genau, dann war in der Gastrolle noch so für eine halbe Minute Stephen Fry plötzlich auf der Bühne. Das war aber nur ganz kurz, aber da standen natürlich auch alle Kopf. Das war ganz schön. Es war interessant, so nach der Auswahl der Sketche, dass da sehr viel, da haben wir vor 40 Jahren schon mal drüber gelacht, aber die Themen sind immer noch relevant. Also damals war es ja noch, also Graham Chapman war ja schon damals offen homosexuell und das war ja auch immer viel Thema und die machen ja auch viel mit Crossdressing und alle möglichen Anspielungen, die damals schon gar nicht geregt sind. Das ist heute ja leider immer noch Thema. Da hätte man jetzt auch sagen, das hätten wir als Gesellschaft hier mal endlich erledigt oder auch als Weltbevölkerung, aber das ist ja leider immer noch sehr aktuell und das ist, ja fand ich halt auch gut, dass sie das auch noch passen.
Stimmt so, habe ich das noch eigentlich noch nie gesehen, dass sie das eigentlich da drüber so quasi über Bande mit thematisiert haben.
Ja, die Pointe von dem Teeshop-Sketch ist ja dann halt auch, dass sie dann, dass das halt auch nur Code dafür war, dass die am Ende zusammen sich eine schöne Nacht machen. So, das ist ja überhaupt gar nicht. Das war ja damals noch illegal in England. Das ist ja auch noch nicht so, noch nicht ganz so alt alles.
Das ist so krass. Ich meine, wann waren diese, wann war die große Zeit?
Das war ja... Anfang der 70er. 1974 war dann der letzte Flying Circus.
Und wie war da die Stimmung?
Unheimlich.
Das müssen ja nicht alle total aus dem Häuschen gewesen sein. Also, dass vorher auch nur irgendeiner da war.
Das war in der O2-Arena, da waren 15.000 Leute da und es war teilweise so ohrenbetäubendes Gekreische.
15.000.
In London gibt es auch nur O2-Arena.
Tatsächlich, ja. Das war ganz, ganz wunderbar. In dem schon angesprochenen Parrot-Sketch gab es dann eine Szene, wo Michael Palin dann so kurz lachen musste. Dann ist John Cleese auch rausgekommen und dann konnten die sich nicht so ganz verkneifen. Haben sie aber versucht, ging dann nicht. Da mussten die ja noch total grinden. Das war total süß, die beiden so zu sehen.
Die müssen auch nach 40 Jahren noch über ihre eigenen Witze.
Aber die haben uns halt so... Man hat die Liebe für das Material und die Freude darüber, wie gut es noch ankommt. Das ist alles in einem Moment zusammengekommen. Und dann ist dieser Funke komplett ins Publikum übergestoßen. Wir sind alle komplett von den Sitzen gefallen. Das war wunderbar.
Wer geschafft ist, überhaupt 40 Jahre alte Witze zu erzählen, das ist irgendwie immer noch lustig.
Ja, da kam auch dieses Genie von Monty Python schon sehr durch, dass das immer noch geht. Und wie gut das damals war. Es gibt inzwischen immer noch niemanden, der da auch nur ansatzweise rankommt. Spontan fällt mir noch Eddie Izzard ein. Aber der ist jetzt auch alleine nur unterwegs und auch nicht als Gruppe. Dieses ganz hohe Niveau ist einfach nicht mehr.
Das sind die aus Dings, bringt es auf jeden Fall nicht.
Ja, sind die aus Dings.
In Deutschland sowieso nicht.
Und wie lange ging die Show?
Das war so mit Pause zweimal 90 Minuten.
Zweimal 90 Minuten? Was halten die alten Herren dann auch noch durch?
Die waren auch ziemlich durch am Ende, ja. Aber es gab hinter so ein Foto von dem Spanish Inquisition Sketch, wo sie aus der Tür gesprungen kommen und da siehst du dann auch wieder Terry Gilliam, der jetzt auch 74 oder 72 oder so ist und der springt so einen Meter in die Luft und macht so den Tada! Ja, das ist schon sehr beeindruckend. Die sind noch alle ziemlich fit. Als jetzt hier Terry Jones, der musste bisschen teilweise so Sketche vorlesen, haben wir sehr geschickt und eingebaut, weil es dann schon teilweise sehr hart war. Das war dieser mit den Pralinen, wo dann Frosch mit eingebaut ist. Dann musste er halt so wie so ein Pralinensalesman quasi diese ganzen, nur aus den feinsten Materialien und das war alles ein bisschen schwierig für ihn, glaube ich. Die anderen hat er aber gut gemacht.
Der ist 72.
Genau, aber jetzt hier den Argument-Sketch, das ist auch wieder Palin und Please. Der ist ja sehr schnell. Immer den haben die auf den Punkt hingekriegt. Das ist auch mein Liebling an der Stelle.
Und Please ist 75.
Die sind alle über 70. 71, der Rest ist da drüber, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Aber das ist unheimlich beeindruckend, dass die es halt noch drauf haben. Das sind halt dann auch echt Schauspieler.
Page ist 71.
Die beiden Jüngsten sind 43 geboren, das sagt ja alles. Der Rest ist immer ein, zwei, drei Jahre älter.
Das war noch vor dem Krieg.
Ja, das ist alles fünf Kriegskinder. Der Neid ist dir sicher.
Auf jeden Fall. Das war das Geld auch wert jetzt.
Was musstest du denn da so anlegen?
Ich habe zwei Tickets für jeweils 150 Pfund gekauft.
Da musst du dein Enkel noch von erzählen.
Das war auf jeden Fall gut investiertes Geld. Das hätte ich auch sofort gemacht.
Finde ich auch.
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Ich habe da zwar kurz vorher von bekommen, aber als dann der Moment war, das ging komplett an mir vorbei.
Da kamen dann noch Flüge und Unterkunft in Non-Non.
Das ist ja dann noch mal teurer. Wie viel Uhr war es dann?
Wie viel Uhr wurde das freigeschaltet? Weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr. Irgendwie 11 Uhr.
So tagsüber.
Ja, also morgens und morgens.
Aber du hast schon dann auch abends vorher in deinem Büro gezeltet und dich da angestellt.
Ich habe es von zu Hause gemacht, weil da habe ich besseres Internet als im Büro.
Zu Hause besseres Internet als im Büro.
Du wolltest jetzt kein Geläster über das Büro sein.
Ja, das Büro ist doch immer da, wo es bessere Internet ist, finde ich. Ja, aber da hast du noch mal ein anderes Thema, was ich eigentlich auch noch mal angehen wollte. Du bist ja viel auf Konferenzen unterwegs. Korrekt. Hilf mir mal, organisierst du auch die ein oder andere ein bisschen mit oder war das mal, oder ist das immer noch so?
Also ich habe mit organisiert oder bin auch dabei, die JSConf oder JavaScriptConf EU, also die europäische Variante, speziell die Berliner Variante, aber wir nennen das EU, weil wir gemein sind, allen anderen Europäern gegenüber. Da bin ich einer der vier Leuten, die das hauptsächlich mit organisieren. Und ansonsten, also ich muss ein bisschen CouchDB machen, weil auch so kleinere Events, da bin ich auch so ein bisschen mit dabei. Und was hier als Buzzwords Berlin läuft, so eine Big Data Search Scale Konferenz, die habe ich mit erfunden, die betreibe ich jetzt nicht mehr mit, aber da war ich am Anfang mit dabei. Genau.
Und das ist auch ganz schön gewachsen, diese JSConf, oder?
Alter Schwede, ja.
Also wie groß muss man sich das vorstellen?
Wir haben mit 120, glaube ich, angefangen im ersten Jahr und dieses Jahr werden es 480. Und das ist immer noch, wir sind ganz vorsichtig, damit das größer zu machen, weil so...
Moment, das sind ja aber nicht 480 Besucher, oder?
Doch, doch.
Okay.
Und das ist absichtlich klein gehalten. Also wir könnten, nachdem was wir so an dem Andrang für Ticketsverkäufe sehen, die sind halt auch innerhalb von, sehr schnell weg.
So wie man es gelernt hat.
Genau. Könnten wir das locker auch dreimal so groß machen. Dann hat es aber auch einen sehr anderen Charakter schnell und den wollen wir nicht verlieren.
Aber da handelt ihr euch dann natürlich in 0,0 an den Elite-Stempel ein, oder? Die Karte gibt es doch dann auch.
Genau. Und da ist unsere Antwort immer, dann macht doch deinen eigenen Scheiß, bzw. macht auch eure eigenen Konferenzen. Und wir helfen denen dann halt auch immer. Die gibt es ja dann auch, ne? Genau. Also inzwischen gibt es auf der JSConf-US-Webseite halt auch so eine Liste von allen Konferenzen, die quasi bei uns inspiriert worden sind und weitergetragen worden sind. Und das sind jetzt, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie viele es da genau sind, aber es sind über 40 Events, die es jetzt auf der ganzen Welt verstreut gibt, die, wo Leute gesagt haben, das ist geil, das wollen wir auch haben.
Aber das sind dann dann separate an anderen Orten zu anderen Zeitpunkten Konferenzen.
Genau, also da gibt es das.
Aber es gibt ja jetzt auch, zumindest bei der JSConf beim letzten Mal war es ja so, dass es noch so diese, ich fand den Namen schon ganz lustig, diese RejectJS gab, wo die Leute quasi Speaker sein durften, die bei der JSConf als Speaker gejectet wurden.
Genau, also bei der JSConf haben wir halt auch das Problem, dass wir halt immer mehr, also wir machen so einen offenen Call for Speakers, oder Call for Presentations, und da sind halt immer mehr Einreichungen, als wir jemals haben könnten. Und auch von denen, die wir gerne hätten, gibt es immer mehr als, also wir haben ungefähr Plätze für 45 Talks in zwei Tagen. Und dieses Jahr haben wir 480 Bewerbungen dafür gehabt. Also das war schon, das ist auch ein ganz großer Einsatz, das alles mal durchzugehen. Wir machen das alles in unserer Freizeit. Da geht ganz schön viel Zeit für drauf.
Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Aber bist du wirklich zwangsläufig der Meinung, dass so eine Vergrößerung automatisch auch so eine Entfremdung zum eigenen Format mit sich bringt?
Mein Freund Paul Kamper, Paul CA auf Twitter, der macht auch Konferenzen, im Moment auch kleiner, aber der hat die Theorie, dass man auch große Konferenzen so richtig toll machen kann. Und ich möchte ihm irgendwann mal die Chance geben dafür. Und ich habe auch eine Idee für eine Konferenz, da können wir später darüber reden, um das mal auszuprobieren. Ich würde auch nicht ausschließen, dass große Konferenzen richtig toll sein können. Ich war zum Beispiel auch schon mal auf der WWDC. Das ist für eine große Konferenz auch schon sehr gut. Aber da hast du natürlich nicht dieses, wir sitzen gerade alle in einem Raum und haben halt das Gänsehautgefühl, außer wenn das iPhone mal präsentiert wird. Und das ist ja dann auch nicht jedes Jahr. Und da geht es ja auch weniger um den Inhalt, der da übertragen wird und nicht über, wie das Event gestaltet wird. Das geht bei kleinen Events besser. Also bis 150, da kann man fast noch alle kennenlernen an einem Wochenende, zumindest mal die Hände schütteln und Hi sagen. Das ist dann halt auch schon wieder vorbei. Aber das bleibt dann alles noch so ein bisschen familiärer und kleiner. Und dann kommt es aber auch so ein bisschen drauf an, wie man so das Drumherum-Programm gestaltet. Also wir versuchen, die Leute so ziemlich lange an der Venue zu halten, indem wir Mittag- und Abendessen halt da auch bereitstellen und dann abends noch Festivitäten gibt, die und so weiter. Sodass man halt auch viel Zeit hat, mit den Leuten rumzunehmen.
Ja, aber wie löst ihr denn das Problem, wenn da so viele Leute dahin kommen wollen? Dann gibt es natürlich die, die letztes Mal auch schon dabei waren und die natürlich, weil sie jetzt schon immer dabei waren, auch wieder dabei sein wollen. Und dann stehen dann auch die, die aber auch gerne mal dabei sein wollen und uns eigentlich da auch genauso gut reinpassen wollen, würden. Und man muss sich quasi entscheiden zwischen, will ich immer mit denselben Leuten jedes Jahr die selbe Pommes essen? Oder wage ich eine Durchmischung und riskiere dabei, mir quasi meine alten Heronen zu verlieren, die ja dann wiederum auch prägend sind für die eigentliche Kultur? Das ist ja so ein genereller Widerspruch.
Wir machen am Anfang, also zum Opening, immer so ein, zeig mal eure Hände, wer schon einmal hier war, wer schon zweimal hier war, wer schon und so weiter.
Wer fünfmal da war, da musst du es nächstes Mal aussetzen.
Nee, einfach nur, um für uns das so zu sehen. Also, die, die beim letzten Jahr dabei waren, das sind maximal 50, also eher 30 Hände, die man so sieht.
Von wie viel?
Also letztes Jahr halt dann 400 ungefähr. Die restlichen sind dann halt neu, die zweimal da waren, sind dann halt nur noch 20.
Und du meinst, da ist ohnehin so eine große Situation, dass das Problem sich gar nicht stellt? Ja, das Problem haben wir jetzt beim Kongress nicht so.
Bestimmt, das ist anders.
Besonders, weil da haben wir halt ein anderes Problem. Weil das war ja, haben wir ja auch schon ein paar Mal besprochen, du warst ja sicherlich auch schon mal auf dem Kongress, oder? Wann warst du das letzte Mal da?
Als das noch hier war.
Ja, vor zwei, drei Jahren oder was?
Ja, das ist jetzt schon ein bisschen her, aber ja.
Aber du weißt ja auch, was passiert ist.
Du bekommst ja mit, ja.
Ja, es war ja eher andersrum. Es war ja so, dass die Veranstaltung quasi an ihrer Limitierung drohte zu ersticken. Gerade weil eben der Anteil von Leuten, die da immer wieder hinkommen, so hoch ist. Und wenn du halt das so beschränkst, hast du halt entweder keine neuen mehr oder du verlierst die alten, was beides irgendwie nicht super ist.
Also da weiß ich nicht, da würde ich dann das auch vielleicht so machen, wie die WWDC das machen würde, das bei Lotterie zu machen, wenn die Größe tatsächlich nicht eingehalten werden kann.
Und wenn es tatsächlich eine Lotterie war.
Bei uns war es ja am Ende eine Lotterie, aber das war gar nicht gut.
Weil hattet ihr dann tatsächlich den Fall, dass die Leute, die die Kultur prägen, dann nicht genug da waren?
Jaja, also viele sind dann auch so... Leute, die halt, was weiß ich, vielleicht schon seit 20 Jahren auf dem Kongress sind, haben halt kein Ticket bekommen, das auch nicht so richtig verstanden, weil die waren immer da. Oder auch so Dreier-, Vierergruppen, die immer zusammenfahren. Und einer kriegt kein Ticket, sind die anderen auch gleich zu Hause geblieben. Und so bei dem letzten Konsolidation in Berlin war das halt schon so etwas grenzwertig, weil du merktest einfach, dass so die kritische Masse an Leuten... Also es ist immer schwer zu quantifizieren, aber so ich, der ich irgendwie seit, ich weiß nicht, kann ich gar nicht mehr denken, seit wann ich irgendwie durchgehend auf dem Kongress war, man läuft so durch die Gänge und man erwartet einfach so einen gewissen Partikel-Kollisionsanteil, wie beim LHC. Das heißt, wenn man da so durchgeht, dann erwartest du einfach mit einer gewissen Frequenz, macht es knack, knack, knack im Sinne von bekanntes Gesicht, bekanntes Gesicht, genau so. Und auf einmal nahm das so massiv ab, dass ich irgendwie so rumrannte und es war nur noch so knack und knack und dann wieder gar nichts und dann knack, knack und irgendwie dachte ich mir so, und man merkte auch, dass die Leute so in zunehmendem Maße, so diesen Suchenden, was ist denn hier eigentlich, Blick drauf hatten, das fühlte sich überhaupt nicht gut an.
Schade.
So, naja, war schade, aber war ja dann auch die Reißleine, dass man einfach gesagt hat, Scheiß drauf, jetzt gehen wir halt in die größte Herberge, die die Bundesrepublik Deutschland derzeit so zu bieten hat.
Naja, offen für alle.
Und dann war wieder alles okay, so.
Ja, dann haben wir zum Glück noch nicht das Problem.
Und wie ist das so mit dem Frauenanteil auf diesen JS-Konferenzen?
Das ist natürlich super toll, wie bei allen Technologiekonferenzen. 70 Prozent. Ja, mindestens.
Ihr macht euch da schon Gedanken, ne?
Ja, also wir haben das jetzt 2012 zum ersten Mal aktiver angegangen, um zu versuchen, zumindest bei den Vortragenden das zu schaffen, dass da vielleicht mal mehr Frauen repräsentiert sind. Und hatten dann passend kurz bevor das bei uns in die heiße Phase ging, von einer anderen Konferenz, wo eine Gamerin, die eine Konferenz geschmissen hatte, die hat sich eine neue Prozedur ausgedacht, wie man das einfach besser machen, das Verhältnis von Frauen ein bisschen größer machen könnte. Und hat das erklärt, wie das geht. Und dann haben wir diese Prozedur einfach mal geklaut und das auch gemacht. Und da habe ich die Erfahrungen auch mal dann verblockt. Da können wir auch einen Link später raussuchen.
Kannst du das mal umreißen?
Genau, da gibt es zwei große Punkte. Einmal der größere und wichtige Punkt an der Stelle ist, ganz konkret Frauen anzusprechen. Also du hast es ja halt oft auch so. So wenig Frauen gibt es in der Technologie ja gar nicht. Ich kenne ganz viele tolle. Also in den sehr Nischen-Bereichen gibt es natürlich ganz viele tolle Frauen auch. Aber die sind halt oft nicht so dabei, ich möchte jetzt hier bei einem Call for Speakers dabei sein oder ich möchte auf einer Konferenz einen Vortrag halten. Wenn man die aber alle kennen, kann man die auch alle einfach mal ansprechen und sagen, hey, würdest du nicht gerne? Und dann gibt es oft als Pattern einfach so dieses...
Also wer spricht die an? Wir jetzt als Orga-Team quasi.
Genau, wir als Orga-Team machen das. Wir halten unsere Augen und Ohren auf das ganze Jahr über. Wir fragen auch Leute immer, ob sie irgendjemand kennen und empfehlen wollen oder so. Und haben dann am Ende eine Liste von 50 Leuten. Das sind jetzt nicht nur Frauen. Wir versuchen halt alle, alle die irgendwie cool sind, die uns auffallen, von denen wir denken, die wären toll, bei uns mal einen Vortrag zu halten, kommen da halt rein und die sprechen wir gezielt an. Also das ist kein gezielter Nufe für Frauen, aber der Frauenanteil da ist halt relativ hoch. Und wir sprechen hier voran, hier möchtest du nicht einen Vortrag halten. Und dann gibt es oft die Antwort, ich weiß nicht genau, worüber ich reden soll, ich bin jetzt nicht Koryphäe in einem Gebiet. Und dann, okay, lass mal 10 Minuten unterhalten. Und da gibt es so ein bisschen die Beobachtung, und ich weiß nicht, wie geschlechtsspezifisch das ist. Wenn du einen Mann eher fragst, magst du nicht einen Vortrag halten, dann sagen die, ja, ich habe hier fünf Ideen, die sind alle scheiße, aber ich mache das trotzdem. Und bei Frauen ist das so, ich habe hier fünf Ideen, die sind, also ich habe keine Idee, von den fünf Ideen möchte ich keine machen, oder ich habe auch gar keine Idee, oder ich weiß nicht, was so wertvoll ist, und überhaupt traue ich mich nicht auf die Bühne, und eigentlich ist das alles doof, und ich will nicht. Und wenn man dann sagt, hier, lass mal quatschen, und dann reichen manchmal 10 Minuten im ERC, hier, was machst du denn gerade, so und so, in welchem Kontext denn, ja, hier bei meiner Firma mache ich das und das, oder haben wir im letzten Jahr versucht, hier nach da und da zu migrieren, oder da jetzt mal Agile auszubringen, oder was auch immer das ist, und dann, wie wär's denn da mit? Und ach ja, cool, das wäre ein Thema. Und wenn man es eine halbe Stunde macht, dann hat man plötzlich fünf Themen. Die kriegt man aus jedem raus, und da dem zugrunde liegt. Und das ist halt, wie gesagt, nicht frauenspezifisch, das kriegt man halt auch bei Männern so raus, wenn die das nicht...
Ja, wahrscheinlich bei den Männern hast du mehr Eifertierchen, und deswegen suchst du gar nicht nach noch anderen Leuten, weil da schon genug sind, die sich selber anbieten.
Genau, das ist so das Standard-Pattern halt.
Ja, Eifertierchen muss man ab und zu mal zur Seite schieben.
Ja, die sind halt alfa, ne?
Ja, deswegen.
Ich hab lieber Betatierchen.
Genau, und eine Möglichkeit, um den Leuten das einfacher zu machen, besonders wenn man sagt, hey, du bist doch eine Frau, magst du nicht von mir einen Vortrag halten? Dann ist das halt so, du möchtest also einen Vortrag dafür haben, weil ich vorhin bestimmte biologische Features habe, und dann ist das auch keine tolle Einladung. Dann formuliert man das natürlich hier. Es gibt halt irgendwie eine, die macht Firefox für Android. Es gibt kein besseres Thema für unsere Konferenz. Da muss man gar nicht weiter diskutieren. Die hat den Port gemacht, fertig, Ende der Geschichte. Also wie gesagt, das geht halt relativ gut. Trotzdem hat man auch immer, wenn man als Mann und als Organizer ankommt, muss man immer damit rechnen, du willst mich doch nur haben, weil ich jetzt hier gerade mein Geschlecht repräsentiere. Und dann machen wir den zweiten wichtigen Schritt, der auch von dieser Courtney Heisty kommt. Wir machen unsere Auswahl anonym. Also wir benutzen Google Docs zum Sammeln der ganzen Beiträge. Und dann muten wir im Prinzip alles, was irgendwie so persönlich identifizierend ist und gucken uns tatsächlich nur den Abstract und so ein paar Nebeninformationen an und bewerten danach, wie gut der Talk ist.
Das heißt, die Talks werden quasi so anonymisiert und entgeschlechtet, entgendert sozusagen.
Genau. Und das kommunizieren wir vorher auch so, wir möchten dich gerne einladen, du kommst in diesen Pool, aber wir wissen nicht, wenn wir die Auswahl machen, ob du eine Frau bist oder nicht. Und diese beiden Dinge, also mehr Frauen in den Pool reinkriegen.
Also im Moment heißt das, dass sie schon so einreichen müssen oder es gibt sozusagen jemanden, der das auch noch mal dahingehend abklopft, das jetzt durch eine Selbstbeschreibung oder sowas sich nicht verrät oder wie weit geht das?
Wir sind dann nicht so super hardcore. Da steht dann manchmal dann, also es gibt immer so einen Abstract, also den Titel, einen Abstract, der den Talk beschreibt und dann noch Notizen, die uns die Beiträge vortragen oder einreichende mitteilen möchte. Und da steht dann manchmal, ja, meine E-Mail-Adresse ist so und so, obwohl wir vorher schon die E-Mail-Adresse abgefragt haben. Da versacken wir das dann manchmal. Ist aber dann auch nicht so schlimm, weil wir eh in dem Modus sind. Wir suchen nach Merit, nach den Vorteilen des eigentlichen Vortrags. Aber wenn wir es spontan wissen, dann kann es natürlich sein, dass wir dann unsere eigenen Biases quasi mit reinbringen. Oder unsere Vorurteile quasi gegenüber Personen. Da ist, weiß ich aber, als Fakt ist noch nie passiert, dass ausversehende Frau reingekommen ist, wo es nicht einen Mann gibt, der einen besseren Vortrag vorgegeben hatte. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es dann ein zweistufiges Verfahren. Also wie gesagt, wir haben 45 Plätze zu vergeben. Wir voten das alle gegen, unabhängig. Wir sind so vier Organisatoren, die das machen. Und da nehmen wir die Top 60 im Prinzip und gehen die durch. Und dann müssen wir so machen, dann machen wir das halt nicht mehr anonym und sagen, hier gibt es zwei Vorträge, die sind beide gut, aber zu einem ähnlichen Thema. Der eine Vortragende kommt aus Sydney und die eine Vortragende kommt aus Hamburg. Und dann sehen wir, die Vorträge sind ungefähr gleich gut. Oder wir gucken uns YouTube-Videos an von den jeweiligen, gucken, wie das so läuft. Und dann nehmen wir vielleicht die aus Hamburg, weil es nicht so teuer ist, wie jemand aus Sydney einzufliegen, weil wir auch so Budget-Fragen beantworten müssen. Und dann dampfen wir diese 60 oder 65 halt runter auf 45 nach diesen Dingen. Weil wir an einer gewissen Stelle auch gucken müssen, sind die Leute auch gute Vortragende, weil wir jetzt nicht so gut sind.
Was hat das jetzt zahlenmäßig für einen Effekt?
Na, in dem ersten Jahr, wo wir das gemacht haben, also von sonst mal so 1-5% Frauen, die sich organisch ergeben haben, oder die wir speziell eingeladen haben, sind wir dann direkt auf 25 gestiegen. Also 25% Frauenanteil. Inklusive im ersten Jahr den Talk, den wir mit 11 von 10 bewertet hatten, den wir auch ohne den Outreach nicht bekommen haben, der dann an der Konferenz auch von allen Teilnehmern als den besten Talk abgegeben wurde, war halt auch von einer Frau.
Hört das auch auf die Teilnehmer? Ein Einfluss?
Das hatten wir gehofft. Da haben wir so ein bisschen das Problem, dass wir unsere Tickets verkaufen, bevor wir das Line-up fertig haben, weil wir sehr faul sind.
Was heißt man Kauf bei euch eigentlich? Die Katze im Sack.
Wir versuchen, das immer besser zu machen, aber weil es eine freiwillige Geschichte ist, geht es meistens nicht. Wir sind jedes Jahr immer später dran, obwohl wir letztes Jahr schon so spät waren. Da spricht sich natürlich auch so ein bisschen.
Aber langfristig müsste das ja ohnehin greifen.
Hätten wir gedacht, hat sich in den Zahlen noch nicht so richtig wiedergeschlagen. Wenn, dann ist es vielleicht so im 5-Prozent-Bereich. Da hätten wir mehr erwartet. Deswegen haben wir uns dieses Jahr gedacht, wir machen auch mal einen speziellen Outreach für Attendees. Es gibt ja inzwischen sehr viele Organisationen, die sich für Women in Tag, Girls in Tag, Trans People in Tag, Lesbien zu Tag oder wie auch immer. Ganz viele, die sich so eine nicht so gut repräsentierten Gruppe zusammenfassen und denen eine Stimme geben oder auch einen Safe Space geben. Die haben wir alle angeschrieben, die wir gefunden haben. Das war dann auch nochmal, habe ich mal zwei Wochen lang jeden Abend Emails geschrieben an die. Und denen gesagt, wir möchten das verbessern und möchten euch gerne einladen. Wir haben eine tolle Konferenz und auch erklärt, was bei der Konferenz alles passiert. Und denen quasi exklusiv Tickets zum Kauf angeboten, die quasi außerhalb des normalen Ticketsverkaufs laufen. Ohne zu sagen, ihr müsst die kaufen, oder die sind billiger, weil wir uns das nicht leisten können, weil wir so eine Non-Profit-Geschichte sind. Aber ihr müsst halt nicht in den ersten 30 Sekunden die Katze im Sack rauf, sondern wir geben euch ein bisschen mehr Zeit dafür. Das läuft jetzt gerade noch, deswegen kann ich da nicht sagen, wie das Ergebnis so ist.
Aber hat denn das... Ich meine, wenn es jetzt noch bei den Teilnehmerzahlen keine... Also gut, bei den Vorträgen lässt es sich ja nachweisen, dass quasi das unmittelbare Auswirkungen, dann unmittelbare Auswirkungen bei den Teilnehmerzahlen, gibt es noch nicht aus den genannten Gründen. Aber was ist denn so die mittelbare Auswirkung auf die Atmosphäre der Konferenz?
Also ich habe mich unendlich viel wohler gefühlt, als es ein bisschen mehr durchmischt war, spontan. Du kennst das wahrscheinlich, wenn du so auf nördigen Events bist, dann guckst du einfach nur, nimmst du so Snapshots mit, du stehst gerade hinten im Raum oder du kommst gerade in den Raum rein oder du siehst dann immer, oh, da ist ja eine Frau, oder ah, da ist ja jemand, oder da, und dann fallen die so auf. Und wir hatten dann mit der 2012 Jazzcon, das hatte ich zum ersten Mal, und ich bin natürlich immer noch heavily biased towards the male gender, zum ersten Mal das Gefühl, es gab nicht einen, wo es dann auffällig war, dass da mal eine Frau in der Szene war, sondern es waren immer genug dabei, also mit denen, die als Attendees und als Speakerinnen da waren, waren es dann schon mehr. Und das hat alles sehr viel entspannter gemacht. Also, das war, das fühlte sich, also es war der Unterschied zwischen von einem Event, der so ein bisschen komisch ist, weil nur Männer oder weil hauptsächlich Männer da sind, zu einem Event, wo Erwachsene hingehen.
Ja, mir ging es auch, ehrlich gesagt, auf dem letzten Kongress auch ähnlich. Ich weiß nicht, ob das euch auch so ging. Also, wo du schon gerade sagst, ob dieser Unterschied, ob es irgendwie total die Ausnahme ist, was einem gerade auffällt, oder ob einfach nur weniger, aber nicht, dass man da jetzt groß drüber nachdenkt.
Auf dem Kongress hatten wir doch schon seit vielen Jahren...
Kontinuierlich.
Es wird noch immer besser, aber der Unterschied fällt halt nicht mehr so auf. Da ist nicht jetzt so ein starker Anstieg gewesen, oder ist es halt wieder nochmal mehr als dieses Jahr davor?
Wir erheben ja leider keine Daten in der Hinsicht. Das fände ich ja mal ganz praktisch.
Andere Diversität nehmt ihr da aber nicht im Angriff. Ich meine, das ist eine unfaire Frage, weil man kann da irgendwie, wenn man da einmal anfängt...
Also, im ersten Jahr haben wir ganz klar gesagt, es gibt viel zu tun. Wir versuchen jetzt erstmal, das mit Frauen zu machen. Dieses Jahr haben wir ganz gezielt halt auch LGBTQ-Communities angesprochen, die wir sowieso auch immer schon repräsentiert hatten.
Oh, die gucken ganz fragend.
Kannst trotzdem erklären. Also, das ist ja dieser Begriff Lesbian, Gay, Bi, Queer und Trans. Ein Q ist aber jetzt nicht drin, aber es zählt da alles mit rein.
Ist auch egal. Ist nicht egal, Entschuldigung.
Der gängige Terminus auf jeden Fall.
Und das ist das TLDR dieser ganzen Geschichte. Also ja, da versuchen wir jetzt noch so ein bisschen mehr zu machen dieses Jahr. Haben wir auch bei den Spekern und bei den Nintendis zum Beispiel auch in andere internationale Communities. Zum Beispiel in Afrika haben wir mal gezielt gefragt, ob die nicht Technologisten rüber schicken könnten. Letztes Jahr hatten wir jemand aus China, der jetzt in unserem Bereich ist, dass die chinesische Entwickler-Community so sehr, die machen halt nur e-chinesisches Ding. Die reden halt auch nicht mit anderen. Die nehmen zwar alles mit, was so geht, aber die haben auch wenig Kommunikation noch draußen. Jetzt will ich den gar nicht vorwerfen. Wahrscheinlich ist das sowohl kulturell, als auch politisch einfach so vorgegeben. Aber da hatten wir mal jemanden da, der auch organisch eingereicht hatte sogar. Und es war wunderbar. Ganz tolle Geschichte an der Stelle. Und da haben wir gesagt, okay, da müssten wir vielleicht auch mal so ein bisschen was machen.
Also ich meine, wir arbeiten auch, wir haben Leute bei uns, bei Wikimedia Deutschland, die halt in diesem Bereich Diversität des Wissens arbeiten. Und ja klar, also nach dem, was wir wissen und messen können und so weiter, gibt es diese Vermutung, 90% Männeranteil bei den Schreibenden und 10% Frauen. Das ist halt schon mal ein großes Thema. Also es kann nicht sein, also da geht Wissen verloren vermutlich. Also wissen wir einfach, dass da Wissen verloren geht. Aber das ist halt nur ein Aspekt der Diversität. Das andere ist halt, es gibt mehr Artikel über den Herren der Ringe als über die Länder Afrikas in der Wikipedia. Das ist ein anderer Aspekt der Wissensdiversität. Die Leute, die da schreiben, sind halt alle aus mittelständischen Familien und haben irgendwas mit Hochschulabschluss oder waren auf jeden Fall alle auf einer Uni oder so bis zum Abbruch. Und so ein Handwerksmeister hat aber auch irgendwie was an Wissen zu vermitteln. Ja, solche Sachen. Und das ist, also man konnte mal schnell in so eine Political Correctness-Debatte, die ich auch gar nicht führen will, aber was halt wichtig ist, ist, man gewinnt damit mehr. Also wir schließen ganz viel potentielles Wissen aus. Also wenn wir halt nur sagen, hier, wir machen unseren Club für die Mehrheit und wir erlauben auch irgendwie keine Patches in der Software von irgendwelchen anderen, das wäre halt Quatsch. Also nur durch maximale Offenheit und dann vielleicht auch mal Outreach und Leute reinholen oder sowas, kann man halt irgendwie so ein Projekt dann letztendlich auch am Leben erhalten.
Also wir haben bei uns dieses, warum wir uns die Mühe machen, gezielt Personen anzusprechen, die auch sagen, ich habe auch gar nichts zu erzählen. Was wir da ansprechen, ist eigentlich, dass wir diese unique Snowflake-Geschichte sind. Also jeder ist schon individuell, auch wenn wir viel gleichgeschaltet sind, hat jeder seine eigene Lebenserfahrung, jeder hat seinen eigenen Musikgeschmack oder ihren eigenen Musikgeschmack, hat folgende Umstände in der Familie gehabt oder war auf folgender Schule und hat immer eigene Ansichten, um Sachen halt nach vorne zu bringen. Also wir hatten, weiß ich nicht, auf der Jazzcoms zum Beispiel jetzt von einem Mann zwar, aber einen Vortrag über Audio, ja, wir haben es gibt Audio bekommen, aber der ist halt so ganz großer Punkrock-Fan, so aus der alten Schule, der dann das Framing hatte mit dem Sexbistles-Konzert von 78, das war dann Teil der Geschichte. Das ist einer der besten Talks, der ist auch bei uns in diesem, wie kann man denn mal so einen Abstrakt schreiben als Beispiel dabei?
Sind eure Talks eigentlich alle online so?
Das machen wir, alles auf YouTube, da kann man alles gucken. Ja, das ist auch ein unheimlich toller Talk. Den empfehle ich auch. Der ist am Ende auch sehr inspirationell.
Aus welchem Jahr?
2012, Stuart Memo. Sorry, youtube.com/jsconf.eudasind alle Videos von allen, ja, es gibt Konferenzen zu finden. Genau. Den zweiten Punkt, den ich ansprechen wollte, dass du meintest, dass eure Wikipedia-Schreibehai so studierte Leute halt viel sind und dass man da viele Leute auch ausschließt, die aus dieser studierten Gesellschaftsebene einfach gar nicht herkommen. Wir haben halt, wie gesagt, mit Hudi eine Firma und da ist, da wir Open Source-Software machen und wir als Firma sehr institutionalisierte Diversität haben wollen, ist zum Beispiel unsere erste Angestellte, so eine alleinerziehende Mutter, die einfach, weil sie alleinerziehende Mutter nicht unendlich viel Zeit hat, ihre Wochenenden und Abend mit Open Source-Software zu verbraten. Und wir erlauben ihr jetzt quasi, sich einen Namen zu machen. Die ist unabhängig von unserem Zutun nicht auf mehreren Konferenzen eingeladen worden, um Vorträge zu halten, weil sie jetzt bei uns arbeiten konnte und kann also teilhaben an dieser tollen Nerdwelt, die wir auch alle so haben, weil wir dieses Privileg haben von zu viel Zeit und tollen Jobs. Und die macht halt auch unheimlich tolle Arbeit. Ihr letzter Talk hat dazu geführt, dass wir mal bei Hacker News wieder waren, wo wir dann auch über 70.000 Leute mit Hooli infizieren konnten. So fies Hacker News ja auch ist normalerweise. Aber das ging halt ganz gut. Und dass es halt unheimlich toll jemanden zu haben, der sonst keine große Chance gehabt hätte, da teilzunehmen. Also wir sehen das halt bei uns im Geschäft halt schon so, da macht das schon Sinn.
Ja, ich denke, da ist einfach auch noch eine Menge zu holen. Und ich bin auch so ein bisschen ungeduldig. Ich bin jetzt schon so lange in dieser Szene. Es wird einfach mal Zeit. Das ist jetzt einfach mal Fahrt auf. Ich finde, es ist schon einiges geschehen, aber es reicht einfach nicht.
Also schön ist zu sehen, dass es so in den Filterbubbles, in denen ich mich so bewege, in den letzten zwei Jahren, dass dieses ganze Thema sehr krass mehr Beachtung bekommt. Also dass verschiedene Communitys, die Python-Community ist da in der Regel ganz vorne dabei, sehr inklusiv arbeitet und dass man da auch ganz viel lernen kann von anderen und das zieht sich jetzt auch in andere weiter. Also dieses allein, dass man so einen Code of Conduct für eine Konferenz oder für User Groups oder auch für Open Source-Projekte, das ist jetzt gerade das neueste Ding. Oder jetzt im Gespräch mal so Code of Conduct auch für Start-ups zu machen, nachdem jetzt mal wieder total furchtbare Sachen rausgekommen sind. Das sind Dinge, die danach noch viel schlimmer. Dass das jetzt endlich tatsächlich mal ein Thema ist von Leuten, die auch nicht nur, ich bin jetzt einer dieser unterrepräsentierten Leuten und ich möchte mich beschweren, sondern auch jemanden, ich schmeiße hier gerade ein Projekt und das ist relativ wichtig. Ich möchte das richtig gut machen, deswegen kümmere ich mich jetzt mal so darum. Das ist sehr schön zu sehen, dass es da Fortschritte gibt. Sehr gut.
So, jetzt kommen wir noch mal auf was anderes.
Now to something completely different.
Genau.
Es gibt noch so einiges, was da irgendwie auch immer wieder andocken kann. Vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz nebenbei, weil ich weiß, dass es auch noch ein bisschen in deine Sphäre reinfällt. Dann habe ich auch mal die Haken an alles gemacht. Was du hier sozusagen by default mit reinbringst, ist aber auch noch mal ein ganz anderes Thema, wo wir so ein bisschen bei Inklusion sind. Was wir noch nicht erwähnt haben, sind ja so die Kleinen. Es gibt da ein Projekt namens Coda Dojo, was ich habe das wirklich erst heute oder gestern entdeckt, was quasi so eine Initiative ist, Jüngsten Poemieren beizubringen, sehe ich das richtig, und das auch so halbwegs weltweit abgefeiert wird, unter anderem aber auch in Berlin.
Und das findet hier in Berlin auch statt und auch diese Woche statt, an diesem Samstag, was ist das, der 12. glaube ich, im Co-op, Co-Working Space, wo du auch mal gerne viele rumhängst, wo wir auch unser Potluff-Workshop gemacht haben, was so ein Co-Working Space ist, der eben insofern sich ein bisschen von den anderen unterscheidet, abhebt, also speziell macht, dass es sich primär eigentlich an Coda wendet, oder kann man das so sagen, schon sehr stark programmiererorientiert?
Ja, genau, so ein bisschen so Designer, Leute, die so Ups machen oder Technologie machen, ist schon sehr, sehr der Fokus jetzt nicht absichtlich, sondern mehr so, weil damit hat es angefangen und das ist so die Kultur, die hängen geblieben ist. Natürlich gibt es auch Leute, die ganz andere Sachen machen, aber das hat sich halt so ein bisschen ergeben. Das, was so ein bisschen sich herausstellt, ist so, dass es da so einen Meetup-Space gibt, den man bekommen kann, wenn man ein Meetup machen möchte, wenn das für lau ist, dann kann man den, wenn der Termin frei ist, kriegt man den Raum einfach für lau. Was es nicht woanders auch gibt, aber da gibt es dann, das ist einfach so vorgesehen, es wird auch sehr viel genutzt.
Genau, so haben wir das ja mit dem Potluff Workshop auch gehalten und so, das ist echt super.
Genau, das ist so ein Community-Asset. Also wenn das weggehen würde, dann würde aus Berlin ziemlich viel wegbrechen. Obwohl, dann muss ich ja jetzt Jens jetzt gerade nochmal einen Softball schmeißen, die von der Wikimedia fangen, damit ich...
Genau, ihr habt ja sowas im Prinzip auch, kann ich gleich auch mal kurz erwähnen.
Event-Räume und so.
Also, wenn ihr irgendwas schmeißen wollt, sprecht mit dem Jens.
Alles, was, sagen wir mal, mit programmieren, Open Source, da ist Co-op sehr zugänglich und was so mit...
Wenn man es auf irgendeine Art und Weise zum Thema freien Wissen damit verordnen kann, ja, genau.
Dann gibt es bei Wikimedia-Räume, die sind auch super.
Uns Co-op ist inzwischen auch oft voll.
Ja, wir sind da mit unserem Workshop auch schon so ein bisschen an die Grenze gestoßen. Und auch die Infrastruktur ist super, so ein bisschen hinten übergefallen bin ich ja, als mir demonstriert wurde, dass man so mit dieser Touchscreen-Appliance in der Wand mal so eben mit drei Tabs irgendwie das komplette 3-Kanal-Video-Recording für den Eventraum veranlassen kann.
Ja, und es gibt halt einen Knopf, da kannst du dann gleich ins Internet springen.
Und streamen, genau, das ist auch noch dazu. Das ist schon so...
Um es klarzustellen, das ist jetzt bei Wikimedia, das ist halt Co-op noch nicht.
Genau, ja, aber das ist so das, was man eigentlich auch haben will und Wikimedia hat es halt. Aber sag doch noch mal kurz was zu diesem Coda-Dojo, was du darüber weißt.
Also, ich kenne zufällig den, der es erfunden hat. Das ist James Welton, der kommt aus Irland. Der hat in Cork, glaube ich, das ist so eine südirische Stadt, hat gedacht, ich möchte mal so eine Computer-AG an meiner Schule haben. Der war gerade dann, war glaube ich in den letzten zwei Jahren oder im letzten Jahr seiner Schule, seiner Abi-Laufzeit. Und hatte dann, da gab es dann halt einfach nichts. Und hatte sich dann gedacht, wenn das keiner macht, dann mache ich es einfach selbst. Das ist einer von diesen. Hat dann mal die Schule gefragt, ob man nicht einen Raum haben kann und musste noch irgendwelche Erwachsenen dazu überreden, dass sie das beaufsichtigen. Und hat dann halt im Prinzip einfach für die jüngeren Schüler eine Computer-AG gemacht nach der Schule. Eine Stunde oder zwei. Und hat denen angefangen, all möglichen Sachen beizubringen. James selber ist irgendwie auch in diesen iOS-Szenen ein bisschen bekannt, weil er, glaube ich, eine Generation iPod zum ersten Mal gedrailbreakt hat. Also er ist auch so ein Hacker-Type. Und das ist bei seiner Schule sehr gut losgelaufen. Er war dann in den Sommerferien, hat das dann weitergeführt. Und dann war er fertig mit der Schule. Und dann haben die Schüler gesagt, wir wollen das aber weitermachen. Also die nächste Generation musste quasi da mitmachen. Und so ist das so ein bisschen gewachsen. Und plötzlich haben andere Städte in Irland das mitbekommen. Und die haben das dann auch organisiert, bis es dann irgendwann in Dublin gelandet ist. Und da haben wir das dann kennengelernt. Da war ich zufällig irgendwie eine Woche vorher auf einer anderen Konferenz, wo er so einen Lightning Talk gehalten hat. Und dann hatten wir noch ein bisschen Budget frei. Dann haben wir spontan mit einer Woche Laufzeit quasi zur JSConf geholt und dann hat er auch mal einen Vortrag gehalten. Und seitdem, also nicht, dass wir da viel Einfluss drauf hatten, er macht das schon selber, hat sich das auf die ganze Welt verbreitet. Ich weiß die Zahl jetzt nicht, aber es ist so.
Ja, hier ist von so 200 Locations die Rede. Und hier gibt es eine Nadel in Berlin, eine Nadel in?
Braunschweig ist das, glaube ich.
Braunschweig.
München gibt es noch, das weiß ich.
Brunswick.
Brunswick steht hier.
Ja, Google, die kennen kein Deutsch.
Und in, warte mal, da sind noch mehr Nadeln. München, Salzburg, Zürich, Köln. Ja, ein Anfang ist gemacht.
Ich glaube, in Hamburg gibt es auch eins, weiß ich jetzt aber gerade nicht. Dann ist das vielleicht nicht aktuell. Es gibt in England eine ähnliche Variante davon, das nennt sich Code Club, glaube ich. Das ist dasselbe in Grün von anderen Leuten, das ist da so ein bisschen populärer. Ja, aber ja, also wie gesagt, Code or Dojo. Dojo ist halt angelehnt an diese asiatischen Kampfsportschulen im Prinzip, die so als Konzept haben, du fängst bei Stufe 0 an und die in Stufe 1 sind, die gerade quasi die Einführung bekommen haben, geben die Einführung direkt den Neulingen quasi. Und die dann die Stufe 2 erreicht haben, unterrichten die, die Stufe 1 bekommen. Und so gibt es halt, es ist man immer gleichzeitig Schüler und Lehrer an jeder Stufe, bis man halt Obermeister...
Warst du da mal dabei? Hast du das mal gesehen?
Ich war nicht bei einem dabei bisher. Das habe ich noch nicht geschafft.
Ja, weil die sagen ja so ab 5 so. Ich frage mich, was da läuft so.
Ja, dann müsstest du da mal die Tiffany einladen. Die könntest du davon erzählen.
Ja, vor allem werde ich mir das mal anschauen, glaube ich.
Genau, ich schmeiße das hier in Berlin. Das ist Fülau. Das ist eine freiwillige Organisation. Es gibt dann immer eine Firma, meistens die in ein Büro stellt, die in Berlin zur Soundcloud. Die haben ja schöne Büros, die dann auch so net zum Computer fähig sind. Die Eltern, die dann dabei sind, bringen dann meist ein bisschen was zu essen und zu trinken mit. Für die Eltern auch was zu trinken, manchmal. Und dann wird sich da, also hier in unserem Fall, es ist dann Samstagnachmittag um die Ohren geschlagen oder Samstagmittag.
Genau, zwei, drei Stunden geht das.
Es ist unheimlich populär. Und ja, die Ergebnisse sind da ganz toll. Es gab jetzt im Elektrischen Reporter mal so ein kurzes Feature dazu. Tatsächlich. Wo du dann auch siehst, wie dann die Kinder mit Augen leuchten, weil sie Roboter gebaut haben. Und da weicht einem natürlich das Herz auch.
So einen ähnlichen Effekt gibt es auch bei einer Veranstaltung, die immer nur jährlich stattfindet. Jugendhackt. Ich weiß nicht, ob du davon gehört hast. Genau, das ist hauptsächlich von der Open Knowledge Foundation Projekt. Und das wird jetzt auch im Herbst das zweite Mal stattfinden. Das ist für Kinder und Jugendliche unter 18 Jahre, die da mit offenen Daten was hacken.
Genau, und die kommen auch so aus, Schüler aus der ganzen, von überall kommen halt.
Das ist eine Veranstaltung, die eigentlich auch aus Großbritannien kommt. Also da macht man viel mit Jugendförderung und Computerwissen und so. Da heißt dort Young Reviled State und hier heißt es halt Jugendhackt, was ich auch den viel cooleren Namen finde.
Das wird ja ein ziemlich cooler Name, aber das richtet sich dann so ab 12. Also schon ein bisschen so slightly experienced programmers, würde ich sagen.
Also da war ich Mentor letztes Jahr und da lief auch jemand irgendwie von, wie heißt dann diese Bude, Open Data City, lief dann raus, richtig weinend und meinte irgendwie, das ist total furchtbar. Die sind irgendwie 13 und die machen einen fertig. Also er wird jetzt nur noch Kinder einstellen. Die bringen es einfach mehr als irgendwie Erwachsene, als Kodam.
Na toll, Kinder an die Macht. Da ist man jetzt schon wie mit 21 ist man, da gehört man schon zum alten Eisen. Oh Gott, meine Rente ist nicht sicher.
Hast du dann James, der hat mal bei mir übernachtet für eine Woche im Sommer 2013, glaube ich. Und er hatte dann so, in meinem Alter und die sind schon so. Und ich so, Alter, komm mal klar, du bist noch relativ jung dabei, mach dir mal keine Sorgen.
Oh man.
Also wenn ihr Kids habt, schleppt die dahin.
Kinder und Computer wäre auch mal ein Thema für CRE, ne?
Ja, ich hab mich da schon mal angetastet. Das war bei mir so Jugendmedienarbeit. Das greift nicht so ganz in den Kinderbereich rein. Also klar, je nachdem, wie man es sieht. Also schon jüngere. Weiß nicht, wo man jetzt große Unterschiede machen muss. Aber ich finde ja ohnehin, also diesen Mythos des Programmieren ist kompliziert. Das kann man einfach, glaube ich, nicht eleganter auflösen als einfach früh damit anzufangen. Weil das ist halt eigentlich, wissen wir alle, eigentlich ist es gar nicht so schwierig. Man kann einen beliebigen Komplexitätsgrad aufmachen. Das ist ja auch das Schöne daran. Aber es ist nichts, wofür man erst mal studiert haben muss. Ich finde, studieren scheint in gewisser Hinsicht kontraproduktiv zu sein. Der alte Witz. Ja, bin ich auf jeden Fall dafür. Puh, na das war doch schön. Kommen wir mal zu was vollkommen anderem.
Na das war doch schön.
Wer will denn eine iWatch haben? Ich habe gelesen, die kommt jetzt. Max hat das schon vor Jahren vorausgesagt.
Ich schließe mich meinem Vorredner an, kommt darauf an.
Worauf denn?
Das ist ja genau das Ding. Ich glaube, es weiß keiner außer Apple. Und ob es dann cool ist, wird man dann sehen.
Ja, aber hat Google nicht Google jetzt schon, haben die jetzt nicht zu Teile verteilt irgendwie?
Also ich habe mich jetzt nicht weiter drüber unterhalten, aber ich habe schon einen gesehen, der diese, ich glaube es war Marstie von Samsung. Wie viele Uhren gibt es das? Also der Jäkel hatte halt eine von, der war auf der Google IO und hatte schon so eine riesen Uhr mit so einem Display. Und wenn er so ein bisschen doller bewegt hat, dann hat die auch von dem normalen...
Eine Runde?
Nee, aber es war ein ziemlich großes Display, fand ich. Und die sah so erstmal ganz schick aus, aber...
Ein großes, kleines Display.
Ja, also für eine Uhr ein großes Display, ansonsten halt schon relativ klein, ja.
Ich glaube, das ist auch so einer der Grundprobleme bei diesem Format.
Ja, glaube ich auch. Also... Hat er jetzt auch nicht. Wir haben uns leider nicht über die unterhalten. Das war halt eine Sendung um was anderes, also die Bitcoin-Sendung, die die gemacht haben, Bitstaub.
Ach, da warst du zu Gast oder was?
Genau, letzten Montag war das. Ich glaube, das war Bitstaub Nummer 5. Da ging es um Mining und um Pools.
Ja, dein Thema.
Hat ganz Spaß gemacht, eigentlich. Und es ist auch deutlich kürzer als hier, nur zwei Stunden. Und nur zu dritt, da musste ich als Gast, wie es hier jetzt auch so ist, das kannst du ja mal durchschnaufen jetzt, als Gast musst du ja die ganze Zeit labern machen tun. Da war ich sozusagen schon ein bisschen mehr Mittelpunkt als hier, nicht so mit Schnarchen und so, sondern da muss man wirklich dann mal erzählen.
Ohne zu wädern, einfach mal eben zwei Stunden Content ausgespuckt.
Gewädert habe ich da bestimmt auch. Die haben da sehr empfindliche Mikros gehabt. Aber es war ganz cool.
Dirk war ja hier auch schon mal zu Gast, da schließt sich der Kreis.
Genau, jedenfalls, der war auf der Google IO., war halt nicht Thema, deswegen haben wir uns da nicht weiter unterhalten und der hatte auch schon so eine Uhr ab. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, von welcher Firma. Eine Google-Uhr selbst gibt es ja nicht, sondern die machen nur das OS mal wieder, oder? Das Android.
Ja, das hätten sie da gerne so, ne?
Ja, und ich glaube, die haben sich aber auch unterhalten. Ist das die? Zeig mal die zweite von rechts da.
Galaxy Gear meinst du wahrscheinlich, ne? Dieses Galaxy Gear.
Ja, die zweite von rechts. Zoom da mal ran.
Zoomen Sie bitte mal rechts ran.
Na, die war es nicht. Die zweite von links da oben jetzt, da wo 1613 steht.
Genau. Was?
Die andere. Oder sind es die gleichen? Ich weiß nicht so genau. Ich habe jetzt nicht aufgepasst.
Samsung Gear 2 Smartwatch. Das ist schon die zweite.
Könnte sein, das ist die, weil ich bin mir nicht so sicher.
Und NEO.
Ja, schick.
Ja, und was ich meine, was können die Dinger denn? Schnell den Apple Air machen.
Das ist halt das Ding, ich glaube bisher versuchen die alles noch das zu machen, was so ein Phone auch kann, also so ein Subset davon, aber ich glaube da muss irgendwie was Spezielles und was Neues her. Sonst bringt das nix.
Keinem fällt was ein. Ja, Apple hat sich jetzt irgendwie so ein Vertriebs-Hiny von Tag Heuer geklickt. Da muss doch irgendwas...
Genau, geklickt ist gut. Also man kann jetzt davon ausgehen, dass ja wirklich schon seit Jahren an dieser iWatch rumort wird. Und beim iPhone war es ja eigentlich die gleiche Situation, oder? Alle sagten, da kommt ein iPhone, keiner wusste irgendwas, aber irgendwie wurde es immer deutlicher und deutlicher, dass da wirklich was kommen wird. Und ich glaube, das Gleiche erleben wir gerade mit der iWatch. Und das ist jetzt nochmal die nächste größte Bestätigung, dass da wirklich irgendwie was kommen muss. Weil ich so richtig geglaubt habe ich da vor ein paar Monaten noch nicht dran eigentlich. Weil ich kann mir das echt nicht vorstellen, was man mit dem Handgelenk da, also ja, was soll man da mit dem Ding? Mir fällt da nichts ein. Aber mir wäre wahrscheinlich...
Auch das iPhone wäre nicht eingefallen.
Ja, schon eher, würde ich fast sagen. Aber dass ich so stark benutzen würde, wie ich es jetzt benutze, wäre mir auch nicht eingefallen, sagen wir mal so.
Also wir haben ja diesen, bei Telefonen zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo wir uns alle einig waren, Telefonen sind scheiße. Das muss irgendwie besser gehen. Und wie genau wussten wir nicht, aber...
Diese Nokias, die schon Farbdisplays hatten, aber es sah immer noch horrible aus, weil die Auflösung war auch scheiße. Die Videokodex oder die Videos, was die da auch immer aufgenommen war scheiße, Videotelefonie gab es schon so ein bisschen irgendwo, aber es war alles Schrott, T9 und so. Und SMS-Anzeigen waren Schrott kein Pro gegenüber, sondern alles durcheinander gemixt irgendwie.
Alles immer irgendwelche komischen...
Musikplayer, wenn es sie gab, waren Schrott.
Genau. Alles irgendwelche GSM-Dienste und kein ordentliches TCP.
Ja, alles war scheiße, aber man wusste irgendwie, dass man im Prinzip so einen Computer da drin haben wollen würde. Nur konnte man sich irgendwie nicht so richtig vorstellen, dass es schon so weit ist. Und das konnte sich ja auch Nokia nicht vorstellen, das konnte sich ja auch Blackberry nicht vorstellen.
Ich glaube, die haben sich das schon vorgestellt, aber die wussten nicht, dass sie jetzt... Die dachten, es ist halt noch drei Jahre hinten. Die dachten, sie können jetzt so langsam weiterjoggen und da vorne, sie werden schon irgendwie ankommen. Oder marktüberbleiben.
Man konnte sich nicht vorstellen, dass sie nicht nur rechts überholt werden, sondern dabei auch noch so...
Stürzen...
.angefahren werden, dass sie sich irgendwie quietschend im Kreis drehen, irgendwann im Graben wiederfinden.
Und das haben wir jetzt bei...
Mit angeklappten Uhren.
Das haben wir jetzt sowohl bei Uhren, als auch bei anderen Wearables nicht. Aber meine Uhr ist so scheiße, das müsste doch mal jemand besser machen.
Na doch, die Uhren sind so scheiße, deswegen habe ich erst mal keine.
Das ist noch der andere Punkt. Ich glaube, das ist alles totaler Quatsch. Irgendjemand hat mal dieses Gerücht in der Welt gebraucht, vielleicht sogar Apple, einfach nur um die anderen, um Research-Ressourcen abzuzwacken, damit die ihre Telefone besser machen können. Das kann man echt nicht ausschließen. Also ich bin jetzt auch einer, der nicht Uhrenträger, und ich verstehe auch, dass es diese Uhrenträger-Kultur noch gibt, aber in meiner Welt ist das, wie ich das verstehe, ist mir anstrengend.
Kriegt hier jemand eine Uhr?
Spontan nicht so.
Das liegt aber daran, dass an meiner Uhr seit ungefähr 20 Jahren das Arm kaputt ist und ich es irgendwie nicht hingekriegt habe.
Du hast halt auch keinerlei Incentive, weil man schaut halt auf sein Telefon.
Wenn man jetzt noch eine Uhr trägt, ist das aus Fashiongründen, oder? Es geht doch gar nicht mehr um die Uhrzeit. Es geht um Styling, um Repräsentieren, um teuren Scheiß am Armgelenk, oder um Coolsein oder so was. Aber es geht nicht mehr um die Uhrzeit an sich, weil die hast du überall inzwischen, vor allem auf deinem Telefon.
Das sind Juwelen, keine Funktionseinheit.
Ich denke, das wird auch nicht weggehen, aber das ist kein Markt, dem Apple interessiert ist. Obwohl die ja... Genau, das ist kein Markt. Das ist ein ganz guter Punkt.
Ja gut, aber warum kaufen die diesen Typen, diesen Vertriebsleiter von Tag heuer ein?
Das ist ein guter Punkt.
Mir fällt nicht ein, was die noch in so eine Uhr reinbringen könnten, was den Markt mal wieder... Wie sagt man? Was da kommen könnte.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass diese Notification Center Extensions da so ein Ding sind. Also zumindest hat Apple mit iOS 8 und den Notification Extensions jetzt was gebaut, was extrem danach aussieht, als würde es zu so einem Device wie eine Uhr passen.
Weil jetzt so kleinerer, definierter Ausschnitt, in dem man sich rein rendern muss.
Ja, genau. Und wo du dann halt auch eine sehr reduzierte Funktionalität hast. Und also, ich meine, eigentlich ist ja eine Uhr mehr was zum Anzeigen und weniger was zum Interagieren. Also diese Quarts, diese ganzen LCD-Uren, diese Digital-Uren damals am Ende der 70er. Wer die miterlebt hat, der weiß, die hatten dann alle fürchterlich viele Funktionen, aber eigentlich hat man sie nie so richtig benutzt, sondern was angezeigt, nämlich die Uhrzeit. Ja, aber diese Taschenrechner-Uren, die waren eigentlich Grütze. Also ich meine, man konnte da mit viel Mühe mal eine zwei Zahlen eintippen, aber im Prinzip waren die nicht dafür geeignet, dass man da einen Input macht bei so einer Uhr.
Die waren in der Schule früher erlaubt bei Mathe-Klausuren, weil man die nicht ordentlich benutzen konnte.
Das hat sich auch keiner angetan. Ganz ehrlich. Und ich glaube, das ist der Punkt, wenn Apple den wirklich knackt, so nach der Art wir zeigen halt Dinge an, und wir zeigen die richtigen Dinge an, wir zeigen sinnvoll die richtigen Dinge an, dann kann das funktionieren, aber auch nur dann. Und wenn ich jetzt aber irgendwie ich schrumpfe mein 5 Zoll Android auf 1 Zoll und hängst mir ans Handgelenk, das kann natürlich nicht funktionieren.
Aber wenn es jetzt Notifications anzeigt, dann ist es ja wiederum auch etwas, was quasi nur in der Nähe eines iPads oder eines iPhones wirklich sinnvoll ist.
Ja, natürlich. Was meinst du denn, was Apple da macht? Meinst du, das ist ein Standalone-Gerät? Du bist gut. Nein, nein. Die wollen schon...
Ich darf was anderes hinaus. Für die Kommunikation könnte man sich halt dieses, wie hieß es nochmal, dieses Peer-to-Peer-Dingsbums, was sie jetzt für AirDrop und... Für ihre ganzen...
Hand-Offer.
Hand-Off heißt es nicht.
Hand-Off.
Hand-Off. Also dieses Ganze, ich merke, du bist in der Nähe und ich tue was mit dir, Nummer. Was bisher ja immer so Bluetooth-Pairing war, was immer ein Schmerz im Arsch war. Das ganze Bluetooth-Pairing ist immer ein Schmerz im Arsch. Jeder, der mal irgendwie Bluetooth-Pairing gemacht hat, irgendwann merkt man einfach, ist jetzt nicht gepairt, warum nicht, mit welchem Gerät ist es denn jetzt gerade gepairt, ach, ist es mit dem anderen gepairt, weil das noch gerade eingeschaltet war, das hat das gesehen und bevor ich mich pairen konnte, hat er sich Auto gepairt und dann kann ich das nicht overreiten oder dann doch und das will er, aber der andere, das ist irgendwie alles so noch nicht da, wo man es haben will. So und jetzt sind sie da mit den neuen Technologien auf der Spur, das vielleicht etwas einfacher zu machen. Also ich wollte jetzt auch nur mal so, wie du auf widgets schaust, so ein weiteres Puzzlestückchen, was vielleicht für irgendwas sprechen kann, was an so einem Ding angedockt ist. Ich meine, es ist relativ offensichtlich, dass diese ganzen Sensorik-Geräte für Apple an sich interessant ist, unabhängig davon, ob sie das jetzt selber machen würden oder nicht. Aber halt auch so diese ganze Home-Sensorik ist ja eigentlich auch ein ähnliches Thema. Ob du nur die Temperatur von deinem Körper, oder die Temperatur von deinem Raum misst, ist technisch gesehen kein nennenswerter Unterschied. Dieses Smart Home und Smart Body Ding geht technologisch zumindest relativ gut zusammen. Die Frage ist jetzt nur, welches Gerät entscheidet jetzt über welches Gerät? Wo landen die Daten primär? Was sind quasi so die Hosts und was sind nur so die Sammelgeräte? Schalter an der Wand, Band am Arm, ist es dann das Apple TV mit dem tollen neuen A7 oder A8-Chip vielleicht auch, was irgendwie auch Games spielen kann und man eben bei alle Körper auch noch mit ausliest. Dann kann man sich abends auf einem Big-Screen irgendwie so seine Leistungskurve anschauen, wie viele Kalorien man jetzt so beim Putzen verbraucht hat. Aber es sind alles so Sachen, wo ich sage, ist das das? Ist das jetzt das, wonach wirklich alle schreien? Fange ich jetzt an, eine Armbanduhr zu tragen, nur weil sie mir irgendwie bunte Notifications anzeigen kann, dann sehe ich die. Und was ich daraufhin tue, ist, ich hole sowieso wieder mein Telefon aus der Hosentasche raus. Also den...
Du hast immerhin die Möglichkeit dadurch, dass du es am Handgelenk hast. Und wenn da so ein Brumm-Vibrator-Ding drin ist, dann merkst du das auch. Wenn dein Telefon irgendwo in der Tasche ist, tief im Rucksack reingeräumt, und es ist noch leise und dann versucht dich jemand anzupingen, dann geht halt nichts. Und wenn dein Handgelenk brummt, das merkst du aber relativ gut. Und kannst auch direkt gucken, oh, den nicht. Weißt du, also... Es macht begrenzt Sinn. Man kann einen Use-Case konstruieren. Ob der jetzt genug Tragfähigkeit hat, ja, das will ich jetzt auch nicht so direkt bejahen. Aber keine Ahnung. Dazu telefoniere ich auch zu wenig. Und Videotelefonie sowieso schon. Also, dass man so mit der Uhr vor der Fresse Videotelefonie machen oder so. Also, ich meine, so was ginge wahrscheinlich zu bauen.
Das kommt ja doch noch.
Es gab ja schon Swatch the Beep in den 90ern mit diesem City-Roof für Kinder oder Skoll.
Hattest du sowas? Nee, hatte ich nicht, aber ich kannte Leute, die es hatten.
Ich hatte City-Roof.
Ja. Keine Ahnung, also das ist so...
Tja, also ich denke auch, dass sie sich jetzt so einen Typen kaufen, der bei einer Uhrenfirma gearbeitet hat, heißt nicht unbedingt, dass sie eine Uhr machen. Sondern das heißt, dass er mit einem Markt, also mit einer Zielgruppe, also mit einer Art Menschen...
Oder noch genereller, der hat eine Expertise, die er sich da erarbeitet hat, die Apple irgendwie braucht, wie er die Apple dann anwendet, ist to be seen.
Ganz andere Sache, genau. Also ich denke, das ist alles highly misleading im Zweifelsfall.
Besonders wenn Apple schon seit 2 Jahren an der Uhr arbeitet, dann kaufen die nicht jetzt erst den ein.
Na für den Vertrieb vielleicht schon.
Na das kann sein.
Wann geht es dann los?
Also alles, was jedes Jahr noch rauskommt, ist ja schon abgesegnet worden. Das kann jetzt nicht sein.
Es kann ja auch jetzt alles abgesegnet und abgezeichnet sein. Du meinst auch vertriebstechnisch schon alles abgesegnet. Ja, ich meine, wenn man hier so nach Acquisitions geht, es gibt ja auch noch, sie haben sicher auch Leute gecastet, diese Amerikanerin, die Spezialistin ist so für die Zulassung medizinischer Geräte. Das ist auch noch so ein Ding, was irgendwie sehr in diesen Health-Bereich reingeht.
Und da kann es ja auch nur vielleicht sein, dass sie nur Expertise brauchen, um zu wissen, hier werden jetzt andere Leute diese Dings bauen. Deswegen müssen wir vielleicht schon mal auf der Software-Seite das richtig machen, dass sie das nicht selber machen wollen, aber wissen wollen, was sie bereitstellen müssen für Leute, die das machen. Genau. Also nicht sagen, dass sie es nicht auch selber machen wollen. Nur kann man auch wieder eine andere...
Aber ich weiß nicht, aber so eine Uhr oder so ein Band... Also ich finde ja auch schon, diese Sportbänder habe ich irgendwie überhaupt gar keinen...
Ja, aber man muss es ja nicht so hässlich bauen wie diese da jetzt. Also gut, die Hörer können das jetzt nicht sehen. Aber ihr wisst, wie diese Plastikbänder aussehen, die noch irgendwas anderes tun. Also das ist so... Da macht der Tag-heuer-Typ schon wieder mehr Sinn.
Vielleicht kommt Apple mit was Cooles um. Das ist so unter der Haut oder so, so ein Vibraphon.
Unter der Haut.
Das ist so ein Vibraphon.
Hier gibt es sogar ein Juwelenschmuck-Halsband mit irgendwie Elektronik drin. Das ist doch irgendwie alles gaga.
Mit Magnet zusammengehalten, ja?
Wir glauben das alles nicht. Das wird irgendwie nichts.
Na, das wird kommen, glaube ich.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Nicht dieses Jahr, meinste.
Na, irgendjemand im Chat meinte ja gerade noch irgendwas mit Kopfhörern.
Ja, hast du das nicht erzählt?
Genau, das hatte ich auch. Also nicht als Gerücht von Apple, aber was ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass sie so ein paar von diesen Funktionen, die so ein Healthband auch machen würde, in die Kopfhörer mit einbauen, dass man da vielleicht so Blutdruck oder Takt, also hier Puls oder was messen kann und vielleicht noch ein paar andere Dinge. Und darüber dann quasi so ein Fuelband ersetzen. Aber das wäre nur so ein Gimmick. Das ist jetzt kein großer neuer Markt. Aber das könnte ich mir gut vorstellen.
Das wäre mal ganz gut hier für meine Kopfhörer. Dann könnte ich dann immer so schön mir auf dem Display visualisieren, wie sich der Geisteszustand so entwickelt. Die körperliche Leistungsfähigkeit. Oh, Dennis, der Herzschlag geht aber deutlich zurück. Und dafür wird ordentlich hyperventiliert. I don't know. Das könnte was sein. So HealthKit online. Und dann streamen wir irgendwie unseren medizinischen Zustand live raus.
Dann gibt es nicht Twitter, wo wir Sachen reinschreiben, sondern einfach unser Puls hängt.
Ich meine, was ich mir selber nicht klar gemacht habe, ist, wie weit das eigentlich schon ist. Und vor allem in einem Bereich, über den gerade eigentlich sehr viel berichtet wird. Auch nicht gerade darüber, nämlich im Fußball. Also, was mir irgendwie überhaupt nicht klar war, ist, dass so Testspiele, die ja jetzt eben Testspiele sind, durchaus so laufen, dass eigentlich alle Spieler so einen Sensorikapparat auf ihrem Körper tragen und alle Körperdaten eben auch live quasi zur Trainerbank übertragen werden.
Das heißt, bei der Formel 1 die ganze Telemetrie.
Telemetrie, das ist vielleicht genau das richtige Wort an der Stelle. Genau, wie bei der Formel 1. Und so läuft dann halt irgendwie auch so der Fußball. Und nicht nur die erste Bundesliga, sondern auch die zweite. So, und dann haben die da... Das ist schon so.
Was ist mit den Test-Spielen?
Bei Test-Spielen, weil das ist jetzt im normalen Spiel nicht erlaubt. Weil das ja einen Vorteil bieten würde. Aus demselben Grund dürfen die da jetzt auch... Bei der WM keine Laptops auf der Trainerbank haben zum Beispiel. Weil das ja alles... Also jegliches digitales Gerät würde natürlich unweigerlich sofort Live-Daten einspielen. Und wenn es nur die Live-Daten sind, die FIFA selber auf ihrer Webseite veröffentlicht. Du kannst da während der WM wegen der Spiele dir auch diese ganzen Statistiken anschauen. Die sind zwar so ein bisschen wonky, wie ich gehört habe. Also geben da etwas widersprüchliche Daten raus manchmal. Also offensichtlich haben sie es da mit der Qualitätssicherung nicht so ganz. Aber grundsätzlich sind Fußballspiele halt Spiele, die einfach über diese ganzen Stereokameras, die da überall verteilt haben. Also das ganze Spielgeschehen wird ja komplett von, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Kameras live getrackt. Das kann man sich gar nicht mehr vorstellen. Also live getrackt nicht nur im Sinne von aus vielen Positionen Videomaterial erzeugt, sondern da ist halt entsprechende Realtime, Erkennungssoftware drauf, jeder Spieler wird verfolgt. Und man sieht das ja auch, wenn die ausgewechselt werden, dann kommt da gleich so die Banderole so. Ja, es ist irgendwie 10,17 Kilometer gelatscht und das ist irgendwie so ein zu viel Prozent über dem Durchschnitt. Aber es geht halt noch viel weiter mit irgendwie Pässe und Pipapo und es geht halt auch irgendwie alles automatisch. Worauf ich hinaus will, ist so dieses ganze Echtzeit-Überwachen, da ist jetzt eigentlich so dieser private Bereich eher noch hinterher. Und können wir uns darauf einstellen, dass wir ja demnächst unsere Tocklichkeit hier auch mal so machen können.
Ja, demnächst kriegt man halt Post von seiner Krankenkasse und da ist dann so ein Bändchen drin. Und wenn du das nicht trägst, wirds teuer.
Ja, und sie sind diesen Monat nur 10 Kilometer gelaufen. Machen sie mal.
Hat uns ihr Telefon gesagt.
Dann schnall ich das Ding an meinen Hund und schicke den bloß.
Der Tätraum schmeißt dir in Citation Needed entgegen für dieses Telemetrie.
Citation Needed. Ja, es gibt auch Quellen jenseits des Internets. Das ist eine Information aus dem Fußballumfeld.
Quelle Fernsehen.
Quelle Freunde. Freunde, Leute mit Plan. Hier irgendwie Healbe oder Heal B. Automatically measure calorie intake, aber eine sehr hektische, aber es ist auch so ein komisches Band. Also im medizinischen Bereich sehe ich das ja alles ein. Also für Diabetiker etc. sind diese ganzen Echtzeit-Analysen natürlich super. Hier wird auch schon mit das Health Kit ja, oder zumindest, wie sie mal meinen, wie es aussehen würde. Oh Gott, das ist eine hektische Website.
Das muss ich leider wieder ausschalten.
Machs weg.
Das ist unerträglich.
Das ist einfach nur am Zappeln. Wo du gerade Kopfhörer sagst, ich war vor zwei Wochen ja beim Apple Store und hab mal alles, was kaputt ist, auf Vordermann bringen lassen. Unter anderem mein iPhone 5. Aber ich hab mir auch mal wieder diese Earphones neu gekauft.
Die kauft, nicht getauscht?
Nein, nicht getauscht. Ausnahmsweise mal nicht getauscht.
Und du meinst jetzt aber diese in-Ear?
Nein, nein.
Die normalen?
Die normalen Earphones.
Die, die dabei sind?
Die, die dabei sind. Hab ich mir mal ein neues gekauft, weil ich hab die ja jetzt auch schon, wie lange gibt's die jetzt, seit zwei Jahren? Und was ich nicht wusste, was ich jetzt auch noch nicht wirklich belegt gesehen habe, aber jemand auf Twitter oder irgendeinem ähnlichen Kanal meinte das zu mir, es gäbe die halt mittlerweile auch schon in einer Revision B. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das irgendwo ablesen kann, hab ich jetzt nicht gesucht. Aber ich hab das auch gemerkt. Also, weil ich hab benutzt die viel und hab mir schon lange keine mehr gekauft, hatte mal mehrere, hab die jetzt alle durchgerockt und hab mir jetzt eben ein neues gekauft und ich bin irgendwie komplett hintenüber gefallen, wie gut die auf einmal waren im Vergleich zu denen. Ich mein, das mag damit zu tun gehabt haben, dass die halt durchgerockt waren.
Aber was war denn dann gut?
Die waren einfach vom Klang her, einfach direkter, klarer...
Ich hab meine neulich mal sauber gemacht. Die waren aus Versehen in der Waschmaschine. Danach klang die auch besser.
In der Waschmaschine?
Really?
Und ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, ob es davor... Ich glaube, es muss davor gewesen sein, da war halt auch so ein bisschen Gang quasi in den Lautsprechern, die so aufs Ort zeigen. Das habe ich auch ein bisschen sauber gemacht. Und dann war der Klang schon ein bisschen besser. Und dann, wie gesagt, aus der Waschmaschine, jetzt klingen die wieder wie neue.
Okay, das mag ein Unterschied sein. Es ist natürlich sehr schwer zu vergleichen, aber ich habe den Eindruck, dass sich da was verbessert hat.
Das kann natürlich auch noch dazu sein.
Aber ohne einen Double Blind Test glauben wir dir nichts.
Wie soll ich den auch machen? Weil ich kann ja nicht, wie ich vor zwei Jahren gehört habe, kann ich auch nicht mehr wieder herstellen.
Du musst jetzt noch alte neue haben und dir nicht sagen, welche du dir gerade reinsteckst. Und dann musst du sagen, welcher jetzt besser wäre.
Das ist schwierig.
Ja, aber dass die Dinger nochmal so ein Innovationsort sein können für andere Sachen, das würde ich gar nicht mal so komplett ausschließen. Naja, und wo ich jetzt gerade sowieso schon so am alles neu macht der Mai und Update, Wahnsinn und so weiter, bin ich irgendwie jetzt mal gleich in die Vollen gegangen und hab mir auch gleich mal noch einen neuen Tarif geholt. Ich bin immer noch beim selben, bin immer noch bei O2. Und bin irgendwie ganz erstaunt, was die mittlerweile findet, für eine Tarifbandbreite da haben. Also irgendwie schon länger nicht mehr angeschaut. Und vor allem, wenn man das mal so mit den Telekom-Angeboten vergleicht, das ist schon ein bisschen lächerlich, was bei der Telekom da so an Datentarifen angeboten wird. Ich weiß nicht, du bist auch bei O2, oder? Was hast du da für einen Tarif?
Na, vor Telefonieren hab ich sowas von, was nichts kostet, keine Grundgebühren und dafür kosten die Gespräche halt so ein bisschen mehr als normal. Aber ich telefonier halt gar nicht so viele. Also wenn dann halt Facetime und Facetime Audio eine Menge. Aber ich hab halt dann für 10 Euro diese 300 MB im Monat.
300 MB im Monat? Das hau ich ja am Tag durch.
Da wo ich bin, ist WLAN.
Ja, da bewege ich halt kaum.
Ja, pendel zwischen den WLANs.
Und die Pendelstrecke ist kurz. Und wenn ich von hier nach weiter, also außerhalb der Stadt pendel, dann sitze ich halt auf dem Motorrad und da brauche ich kein Netz oder sehr wenig. Und dann reichen die 300 MB. Ich musste aber in letzter Zeit die 200 nach 300 aufstocken. Ich hatte noch die alten 200. Und da musste man anrufen und sagen, ja hier macht man jetzt von 200 nach 300. Weil die hatte ich schon oft dran gekratzt. Und so, wenn jetzt hier Easter Hack ist und so da und kein Netz auf dem Easter Hack, dann sind die schnell weg gewesen. Da hatte ich dann mal wirklich eine... Das war ja genau... Ich hab die Umstellung am 9. Und das Easter Hack war an welchem Datum? Das war gleich so kurz am 14. oder so. Easter Hack kann das sein? Ich hab keine Ahnung mehr. Und dann war gleich für den restlichen 20 Tage meine Daten im Eimer. Das war nicht so schön. Aber ja, ich komm mit den 300 eigentlich klar.
Ich hab so ein E-Plus für... Gigabyte für 10 Euro Geschichte.
Gigabyte für 10 Euro?
Und das reicht bei mir gerade eben. Also ich bin dann öfter auch in Nicht-WLAN unterwegs. Aber also damit komm ich meistens zurecht. Und dann, weiß ich nicht, zwei Mal im Jahr komm ich halt an die Grenze, dass ich dann noch zwei, drei Tage mit Edge unterwegs bin.
Eigentlich überall, wo ich bin, auch in den Cafés, wenn du wirklich da länger sitzt irgendwie, dann sag mal, habt ihr auch WLAN-Passwort? Dann geht das eigentlich schon. Eigentlich haben die immer alles irgendwie da am Start. Und dann klappt das.
Also ich könnte so nicht arbeiten.
Ja, du bist ja auch kompromisslos und lädst wahrscheinlich sofort die Sekunde, wo du aus dem Haus kommst, fällt ein, dass du dir irgendeine Podcast-Show noch nicht geladen hast. Und willst du dann unterwegs runter landen? Also was hab ich ja nicht.
Ich sehe überhaupt nicht ein, mich irgendwie anders zu verhalten, nur weil ich irgendwie 500 Meter weiter nach links gegangen bin.
Ja, verstehe ich auch.
Ich unterstütze das.
Verstehe ich auch. Aber ich hab keinen Bock dafür, irgendwie mir 30 oder 50 Euro irgendwie an Arsch zu kleben pro Monat.
Was zahlst du denn real?
15 Euro. 10 Euro für diese Flat und 5 Euro noch für so ein bisschen SMS und Telefonieren.
Genau, für die Android-Freunde und Telefonieren.
Man soll die sich wiederholenden Kosten, die laufenden Kosten, die sollte man klein halten und die einmaligen Kosten, da ist so ein bisschen egal. Und 15 Euro sind halt monatliche Kosten, die muss man gering halten.
Okay, das kann ich nachvollziehen. Ich wollte auch meine monatlichen Kosten mal ein bisschen reduzieren, deswegen habe ich jetzt auch mal so einen Tarifwechsel gemacht, das wird mir locker 30 Euro im Monat sparen. Aber es gibt dann halt schon auch so, sagen wir mal, so die richtigen Prittlauf-Tarife bei O2. Und das hat sich auch nochmal durch ein paar neue Informationen noch mal verbessert. Also es gibt da erstmal mittlerweile einen Premium-Tarif, für 70 Euro im Monat, das ist mal locker irgendwie serienmäßig sogar schon eine 10 GB nachgeworfen. Ja, plus so mit, naja, ist halt so all features included und vor allem mittlerweile sind auch halbwegs, also, nein, nicht halbwegs, ansatzweise akzeptable Auslandstarife damit auch verbunden. Also du kriegst dann auch mal so dein halbes Gigabyte im Ausland, wo du es irgendwie auch einfach brauchst, also ich zumindest. Und wie gesagt, also ich will gar nicht anders, ich will irgendwie überall gleich viel Netz haben. Deswegen stört mich das ja auch, dass diese Computer irgendwie das nicht haben.
Das ist schon.
Und naja, die zweite interessante Information ist, man kann, darüber hatten wir ja letztes Mal schon geredet, da war es noch ein bisschen unklar, ich weiß nicht genauer, also ich rede jetzt nur für O2, ich weiß nicht genau, wie das bei anderen aussieht, aber du kannst halt, wenn dein Kontingent aufgebraucht ist, egal wie es ist, also für 5 Euro, quasi dein Kontingent nochmal freischalten lassen. Offiziell heißt es zwar, sie geben dir 500 MB zusätzlich, aber technisch können sie das gar nicht unterscheiden. Die setzen da einfach nur einen Counter auf Null und wenn du vorher 5 GB hattest und du bist mit deinem 5 GB durch, wo sie immer alle anfangen zu jammern, so ein Paket, das ist alle und ich verhungere, kann man halt bei der Hotline anrufen und sagen, hier einmal nachschubt, das darfst du genau einmal machen pro Monat, dann kannst du quasi nochmal für 5 Euro Aufschlag deine Datenmenge verdoppeln.
Das heißt also, man holt sich gar nicht hier für 72 Euro den mit 10 GB, sondern nur für 45 Euro den mit 5 GB und du ruf dann an und verlängert für 5 Euro extra.
Genau, da hast du dann zwar nicht auch noch deine Auslandstelefonierminuten, 200 Minuten auch noch mit drin, also dieser Supertarif ist halt wirklich gut, wenn du wirklich viel im Monat herstellst.
Die anderen Sachen sind ja eh alle flat.
Ja genau, aber die Auslandssache macht es an der Stelle eben aus. So 200 Minuten im Ausland rumtelefonieren, das kann einen schon richtig arm machen. Und das bessert sich. Und damit nicht genug, wenn man selbstständig ist, kann man das auch noch geltend machen. Das heißt, du musst dir ja irgendwelche Finanzamts, tra la la, irgendwas wollen die da belegt wissen. Also wenn du das quasi ausreichend glaubhaft machen kannst, dass du selbstständig bist, dass man selbstständig ist, gibt es sowieso nochmal 50% Daten nochmal obendrauf. Also wenn du quasi einen 5 GB Tarif hast als Selbstständiger, bist halt schonmal bei 7,5. Entsprechend ist das eben für die niedrigeren Bereiche. Ja, so, jetzt habe ich irgendwie mal meinen Tarif gewechselt. Welchen hast du denn jetzt? Ich habe jetzt diesen XL Professional 5 GB, 44,99. Ja, 7,5 dann halt. Plus irgendwie 5 Euro Nachschlag, wenn es hart kommt, macht 15 GB und bin halt bisher so... Also ich habe jetzt in diesem WM-Monat habe ich es halt mal wieder geschafft, die 10 GB so richtig zu reißen.
Guckst du dann auch Spiele auf dem Handy?
Na klar, ich setze mich in den Garten und...
Kein WLAN im Garten?
Gibt es halt irgendwie, dann wird dann halt mal zweieinhalb Stunden bis zum Elfmeterschießen 3G, HD gestreamt, so, über Mobilfunk, because we can. Also, ich meine, ich kann natürlich viel sparen, so, aber ich kann halt auch später mal meinen Kindern davon erzählen, aber weißt du noch, damals, 2014, als wir irgendwie noch 3G gestreamt haben im Garten, oh, das war ja harte Zeit.
2D, 2D fragen sie denn.
Alles noch in 2D.
Genau, und dann hatte das noch einen weiteren Effekt, dass ich nämlich festgestellt habe, hoppala, jetzt darf ich ja auch noch LTE machen. Das hatte ich ja auch noch nicht. Ich hab das Gefühl, ich bin ein Jahr lang wirklich in einer Eistonne gewesen und hab irgendwie keinerlei technologischen Fortschritt mehr mitbekommen. Ja, ihr wisst, das Update. Und dann durfte ich auch noch erfahren, dass in meinem Garten, wo bisher irgendwie Versorgungsengpässe waren, O2 auch noch hervorragendes LTE betreibt. Sodass ich sozusagen so wirklich so komplett aus der Diaspora jetzt in so ein Hochversorgungsgebiet gelangt bin, ohne mich auch nur einen Meter bewegt zu haben. Und noch toller ist, das LTE reicht hier auch wunderbar in die Metaebene rein. Und jetzt habe ich mir gerade so noch diesen Stick geholt, den...
Ich weiß, diese Sendung hier wird gerade über LTE bestrengt.
Nein, das weiß man noch nicht. Aber den in der letzten Sendung von Clemens empfohlenen Stick, den habe ich mir jetzt mal geklickt. Der wird ja hier hoffentlich morgen oder übermorgen reinrauschen. Und dann ist das halt hier für meine Fritzbox quasi mein Backup. Verstehe. Also es wird erstmal so nicht benutzt, aber sollte mir halt wieder mal das DSL hier die Füße hochnehmen, das kann ja schon mal vorkommen. Dann kann ich halt auch anders. Und das ist irgendwie alles ganz cool. Also ich finde, sagen wir mal so, die ganze Tarifgeschichte bei O2 entwickelt sich da so schlecht nicht. Wobei, ich sagen muss, auch diese Aldi-Talk-Sache, die ich gerade noch im Einsatz habe, ist eigentlich auch sehr interessant, weil da kriegt man ja quasi für zwei Euro am Tag ein Gigabyte offiziell. Und praktisch ist es, glaube ich, auch nicht begrenzt. Das heißt, genau genommen, wenn man jetzt jeden Tag das benutzt, bist du bei 60 Euro, hast aber 30 Gigabyte und eigentlich sogar noch mehr, was jetzt auch nicht so der schlechteste Tarif ist, wenn man halt jetzt wirklich diesen hohen Datenbedarf auch hat. Aber da ist ja eher so ein Ort, wo ich nur ab und zu mal bin, idealerweise so das Wochenende. Nur die Tage will ich abgedeckt wissen, aber dann möchte ich nicht gerne auch noch mal so an so einer Drossel hängen, sondern ordentlich den Datenadler machen und das funktioniert damit ganz gut. Was bloß irgendwie vollkommen bekloppt ist, weil ich habe mir aus anderen Gründen, weil woanders gerade Netz fehlte, mir noch mal so eine Aldi-Talk-Karte geholt und dachte mir so, oh super, die konfigure ich mir jetzt mal wieder genauso, was mir eigentlich speziell nicht gelungen ist, weil naja, bei Aldi ist ja auch so ihre Schwierigkeiten haben mit dem Software- Entwicklungsmoment, der Bezlebssysteme mitzuhalten. Aus irgendeinem Grund, also du kaufst ja diese SIM-Karte, bei Aldi einfach so, da gibt es quasi nur das Produkt SIM-Karte und dann musst du dir selber, musst du dich dann online registrieren, trägst halt die Kartennummer und die Telefonnummer ein, also quasi als zugehörige Nummernpärchen, um dich dann automatisch zu autorisieren dafür und dann sagst du, welchen Vertrag du haben willst. Da hast du halt so alle möglichen so und so viel kostet das und das Tarife, die eben so naja, ganz okay sind, aber man muss halt schon wieder nachdenken. Nur dieser eine Tarif, den ich gerade beschrieben habe, der nur an Tagen, wo es benutzt wird und dann Gigabyte und dann nur zwei Euro, den kriegst du nur, indem du diese komische Webstick-Software aktivierst und dann darüber freischaltest. Also nicht, dass ihr nicht auch noch auf dieser fucking Webseite einen Button machen könnt, mit das ist der Tarif, den ich haben will. Nein, du kriegst den Tarif nur, wenn es dir gelingt, diese Software zu installieren, den Stick in Betrieb zu nehmen, um dann in dieser bekloppten Kontrollsoftware auf das Flag zu klicken, dass das doch bitte der Tarif ist, den du gerne haben möchtest.
So, und die Software läuft mit irgendwie 10.6.0 noch?
Weiß ich nicht. Ich hab's jetzt mal auf dem aktuellen Mavericks versucht zu installieren. Ich hab also extra noch mal eine separate Partition und so, weil das ist so diese Art von Software, die ich gar nicht erst deinstallieren möchte.
Für sowas hat man eine virtuelle Maschine mit einem XP.
Ja, das wäre jetzt, sagen wir mal, der nächste Schritt, weil so hat es eben nicht funktioniert. Also wir sind mittlerweile so weit, dass man noch nicht mal diese abdoppelklicken kann, die da drauf ist. Also die startet dann einfach nicht. Dann hab ich da reingeschaut, dann ist da so ein Installer-Package drin. Das ist also nur so ein Wrapper um den Installer. Den kann ich dann starten, aber der will dann irgendwie auch wieder irgendwas nicht ausführen. Und das ist alles ganz furchtbar und grausam. Mit dem Ergebnis, ich hab jetzt so eine SIM-Karte, die ich nicht benutzen kann, weil ich nicht in der Lage bin, den Tarif auszuwählen, den ich haben will, weil er eben nur über diesen Umweg einer Treibersoftware geht. Das ist einfach... Leute, echt! Ich weiß nicht, ob man da vielleicht Erfolg hat, wenn man einfach anruft und die so lange anschreit, bis man den richtigen Tarif bekommt. Aber ich befürchte, da ist niemand, den man anschreiben kann. Vielleicht hört ja jemand aus dem E-Plus-Datenservice zu und hat da genauere Informationen, ob es nicht doch irgendwo noch so ein Option-Click oder Hintenmenü oder eine URL, die man normalerweise nicht anklicken kann, gibt.
Irgendwer hat doch mal den Netzwerk-Traffic mitgeschnitten und kann dir dann sagen, welche Rest-Uplieder angehauen oder welche XML-RPC-Uplieder aufbauen.
Ja, online geht es ja eh. Irgendwas muss es ja sein. Aber ich finde, das alles völlig bekloppt. Also auf jeden Fall, wenn man in Berlin wohnt und korrekt LTE haben will, ich habe hier sehr gute Erfahrungen gesammelt in den ersten Tagen. Ah, hier kommt schon der erste Tipp irgendwie. Anderen Zugangspunkt wählen, funktionierte mal tagesflat.e plus.de Ah, ja, das kann sein.
Stimmt.
Guter Punkt, dass man einfach das Ding nur in so eine Fritzbox reinmacht und dann einfach einen anderen APN auswählt. Das wollte ich mal gesagt haben.
Super. Wir schimpfen jetzt jede Sendung über den Mobilfunkprovider, in der Hoffnung, dass es besser wird, oder?
Ja, es wird ja auch besser. Also, man muss nur lange genug schimpfen. Ich kann jetzt nicht so schön schimpfen, wie Clemens das schimpfen kann, aber so ein bisschen aufgeregt habe ich mich ja auch.
Vor allem müsste man wahrscheinlich auf Italien schimpfen, damit es auch in Italien besser wird. Das habe ich nämlich gestern noch vergessen zu erwähnen. Bei dieser Dreh, dieser Drei, da ist es, wenn man da den Datentarif geklickt hat und man hat mehrere Stunden keine Daten gezogen, dann bekommt man wieder einen Captive Portal. Also ein Captive Portal bei einem Mobilfunkprovider ist halt einfach richtig gruselig. Es ist einfach super traurig.
So, will noch jemand Getränke? So solche? So bunte?
Ich habe noch.
So, Roddi, du hast da irgendwas über Rocker-Partys noch aufgeschrieben.
Ja, und zwar nehme ich jetzt erstmal einen Schluck Bier.
Mach mal, ich hole mir auch mal eins.
Und zwar meine Twitter-Follower haben das teilweise schon mitgekriegt. Ich singe da jetzt in so einem neuen Chor. Du singst in einem Chor? Ja, und die haben sich darauf spezialisiert, bei Bands Background-Chor zu sein.
Wieso hast du deine Band gewechselt?
Nö.
Ach so, hast du eine weitere Band hinzugefügt?
Naja, ein Chor halt. Aber der Chor singt halt gerne auch als Background-Chor zu irgendwelchen Bands. Ja, die nennen sich wirklich Hardchor auch. Naja, so als Untertitel. Und zwar, es gibt eine Band, also die nennen sich Band aus dem Rheinland. Die heißen Van Canto und machen Acapella Heavy Metal. Das sind fünf Leute, die singen und ein Schlagzeuger. Dafür, dass die wirklich nur Gesang machen, ist es ein ganz schön fetter Sound. Und die haben halt, wenn sie aber auf der Bühne sind, können sie halt keine Spuren overdubben oder so. Und deswegen haben sie sich halt einen Chor rangeholt. Und da mache ich jetzt mit. Und wir werden dann in Wacken auftreten.
Ach, das ist ja spannend.
Und zwar, ich glaube, der Samstag ist es als letzter Act auf der Partystage. Wer sich das angucken will, der sei herzlich eingeladen. Also Wacken.
Das ist doch irgendwie so eine größere Ansammlung von Menschen.
Auf kleinere Ansammlungen von Kühen treten, treffen, mit viel Lärm dabei.
Und welchen Mädchen-Namen rufen sie dann immer? Helga? Achtung mal drauf. Das war nicht Wacken, wo es losging oder so ein anderes.
Keiner weiß, wo es herkommt. Es ist auf allen Festivals.
Ja, es gibt da so verschiedene Mythen.
Bei jedem das Erste, wo es gehört hat, ist natürlich, bei mir war es auf dem Bizarre-Festival, da kommt es her. Natürlich gab es das auch schon.
Irgendwo wird es mal das erste Mal gewesen sein, dass halt, weiß nicht, weil er besoffen oder so, leicht dir also auf jeden Fall ausreichend verpeilt. Und er suchte halt irgendwie seine Freundin Helga. Und rannte dann halt irgendwie, vielleicht Sturzdrunken, vielleicht, man weiß es nicht. Also er lief auf jeden Fall rum und rief nach ihr, ohne wirklich damit aufzuhören. Und Helga! Und jetzt ist das sozusagen so das Mehen auf solchen Veranstaltungen.
Da wird auf der richtigen... Helga in Klammern Ruf.
Genau, Helga in Klammern Ruf. Da sind dann auch so verschiedene Verschwörungstheorien, wo das jetzt herkommt. Die Seite wurde natürlich gelöfft. Nee, wurde sie nicht. Da fehlt doch der Klammer zu. Da war der Link nicht vollständig. Entschuldigung, da könnte man ja auch nochmal... Genau, hier Running Gag auf Massenveranstaltungen. Genau, die veranstalten wir halt. Das ist auch lustig. Ja, genau. Und dann fangen halt alle an, auch Helga zu rufen. Und es nimmt halt überhaupt gar kein Ende. Und viele sind auch schon total genervt. Aber so richtig sein lassen kann man es auch nicht, weil es ist halt wie Rick Roll, den kriegst du halt nicht weg. Helga, könnt ihr ein Helga-Song machen mit eurem Hardchor auf Wacken? Das wäre auf jeden Fall schon mal ein Erfolg für sich. Wenn ihr das ordentlich intoniert bekommt, dann könnt ihr vielleicht für die nächsten zehn Jahre definieren, wie Helga gerufen wird auf Open Air Veranstaltungen. Das steht dann wiederum in diesem Artikel.
Wie gesagt, wir sind ja nur quasi der Hintergrundchor zu diesen Jungs von Wankanto.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja der Hintergrundchor des ganzen Open Air Festivals.
Und vor letztes Wochenende hatten wir das erste Mal Probe mit Schlagzeug. Und das war echt eine Erfahrung. Also da hat dann jeder seine In-Ear-Kopfhörer, wo er irgendwie den Monitor-Mix hört. Und dann ist das Schlagzeug aber so laut, dass es über alle Mikrofone wieder so stark reinkoppelt, dass du im In-Ear-Mix wieder nichts hörst, weil da nur Schlagzeug ist. Also es war ein bisschen hart. Aber wir sind nicht völlig abgekackt und ich bin guter Dinge, dass wir das ordentlich hinkriegen.
Gibt es da schon mal eine Referenzaufnahme?
Cover-Version?
Du kannst dir ja mal die Webseite von Van Canto angucken. Die machen teilweise Coverns und Sachen von anderen Heavy-Metal-Bands, machen aber auch viel eigenes Zeug. Also das ist halt Heavy-Metal, das muss man halt mögen. Sag ich jetzt einfach mal so. Das ist so nicht jedermanns Sache. Aber sag mal ein Titel. Fight for Your Life zum Beispiel. Wie? Also das wird bestimmt ganz, ganz großer Spaß. Ja, das ist, ja, Heavy Metal ist immer sehr stark aufgetragen und so.
Jaja, es gibt einen Napalm-Store. Es gibt ja auch Musik hier oben, da kann man irgendwie einen Player anmachen. Sollte jetzt schon was zu hören sein?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Moment, ah ja genau, da kommt was. Moment, ich mach das mal.
Siehst du, die haben nämlich einen Webplayer auf der Seite.
Ja, ich spiele das mal langsam ein hier. Wie sie hören, hören sie nichts.
Vielleicht da bei Media da unten. Vielleicht ist der Webplayer auch irgendwie... Keine Ahnung.
Bei Media? Nee, da oben spielt eigentlich schon was.
Sicher?
Ja, aber ich kriege hier auch gerade einen Ton rein. Warte mal, ich bin gerade...
Jetzt müsste man seinen Falschengriff haben.
Ja, die Blödsinn, das ich jetzt hier auch gerade misst.
Bloß nicht die Aufnahme versacken.
Oh, live an Reaper rumklicken.
Ja, da bin ich ganz hart.
No risk, no fun.
Ja, aber zumindest hab ich jetzt schon mal hier dieses Echo weg. Aber jetzt hören wir auch hier tatsächlich nichts aus dieser Webseite, aber ich weiß nicht, warum. Da ist ja doch nichts zu hören, aber ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie ich hier... Man kann da irgendwie draufklicken, aber es tut irgendwie nichts. Aber es spielt nichts ab. Achso, wahrscheinlich fehlt mir Flash.
Das ist doch... Ah, du kannst es mal bei YouTube versuchen.
Nee, es ist einfach wieder so eine Webseite, die einfach Flash haben will, nehme ich mal an.
Das war das andere Flash.
Am Mischpult liegt es nicht. Es liegt an dieser Webseite. So viel dazu.
Hatten wir lange nicht.
Nee, ein paar Sachen haben wir noch. Ach so, also du singst. Und Wacken ist aber schon ausverkauft wahrscheinlich. Also das hat jetzt eh keinen Sinn mehr.
Keine Ahnung.
Wer hat das gestreamt?
Wo ist denn das überhaupt?
Wo ist denn dieses Wacken?
Ist das der Ort Wacken?
Von hier aus hinter Hamburg ungefähr nochmal genau soweit. Also hier ist jetzt Berlin.
Aha, hier Wacken Open Air Festival. Guck an, das ist sogar sein eigener Wegpunkt.
Keine Ahnung, ich bin da immer nur hingefahren worden. Insofern weiß ich es nicht so genau. Aber da irgendwo nördlich von Hamburg, eine ganze Menge nördlich von Hamburg.
Aha, da ist ja auch eine Menge Platz, nicht?
Das ist schon Nordfriesland, oder?
Der Ort besteht wahrscheinlich im Wesentlichen aus diesem Festival.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob du je diesen Film Full Metal Village gesehen hast. Wenn nicht, guck ihn dir an. Sehr, sehr spaßig.
Full Metal Village.
Full Metal Village, ja. Das ist ein Dokumentationsfilm einer Koreanerin über das Wacken-Festival. Und das muss man mal gesehen haben. Das ist wirklich sehr, sehr großartig.
Das sieht aber jetzt gar nicht so groß aus hier.
Ja, zoom mal ein bisschen raus.
Ja, was? Da ist ein Ort, das ja hier schon direkt...
Ja, aber es ist ja nicht im Ort, es ist da irgendwo auf der Kuhwiese oder auf diversen Kuhwiesen.
Wie viele Tausend Leute kommen da?
Keine Ahnung, aber es ist angeblich das größte Heavy-Metal-Festival auf der Welt. Also insofern, das ist schon, ich glaube, 70.000 oder so, irgendwie so was.
Schauen wir mal, was auf der Wikipedia steht. Das ist schon noch der Ort, aber ich glaube...
Weltgrößte Metal-Festival.
So, wir sind gespannt.
Ja, 80.000.
85.000 Menschen davon, 75.000 zahlend.
Ja, kannst mal sehen, was machen die anderen 10.000?
Ja, nicht zahlen, arbeiten, ja.
Eingeladen werden.
89 ging das erst los. Nicht schlecht.
Wir vergleichen das mal mit dem Fusion Festival. Das dürft ihr mittlerweile auch einen entsprechenden Eintrag haben.
Oder? Ja, 70.000.
Kann schon mithalten.
War ja jetzt gerade.
Ja, war von euch einer da?
Ich kenne auch nur Leute, die da waren.
Unter anderem Netzpolitik Org irgendwie komplett Belegschaft, die damit sozusagen die Grimme Online Award-Preisverleihung vergeigt haben, weil sie da sozusagen nicht da waren. Also Grimme Online hat es eigentlich eher vergeigt, weil die haben ihnen dann irgendwie so diesen Preis gegeben.
Die haben das aber alle am Stream geguckt. Auf dem Fusion-Festival haben sie geguckt, wie sie ihren eigenen Preis gewonnen haben bei Grimme.
Ja, passt doch eigentlich zu einem Online Award, oder?
Über 3G, oder?
Keine Ahnung, hat mich da gestern erzählt.
Oder deinen LTE-Dings hatten sie wahrscheinlich auch.
Ja, ich glaube, C-Punkt dürfte da schon dafür gesorgt haben, dass sie da ordentliche Bandbreite hatten für den Event.
Ich war letztes Jahr zufällig da, das ist ein ganz obskurer Event. Das ist so eine ganz Standardpreisverleihung der alten Schule. Nicht Fusion, sondern Krimonline. Warum warst du da? Meine Freundin war nominiert für den Aufschrei-Hashtag.
Hat er auch gewonnen, ne?
Ja, genau.
Ja, richtig. Wacken.
Du berichtest dann, ne?
Also, irgendjemand auf Twitter meinte, man könnte ein Hörer-Treffen dort machen. Ja, ich weiß ja nicht.
Du kannst gerne ein Hörer-Treffen machen. Ich werde nicht vorbeikommen. Das kann ich dir jetzt schon sagen.
Ich sag's mal so, ich kann nicht genau sagen, wann ich da wie Zeit habe, aber ich kann ja einfach sagen, liebe Follower, wenn ihr wollt, können wir uns jetzt in einer halben Stunde da und da treffen.
Einfach nach Helga rufen. Der im schwarzen T-Shirt mit den langen Haaren.
Total auffällig mit so einem bunten Logo drauf.
Und irgendwann rennen dann die ganzen Helga-Rufe wie so Ameisen im Kreis.
Ich wollte noch mal ganz kurz was sagen zu Instacast. Das hatte ich glaube ich letztes Mal schon angesprochen. Das scheint ja tatsächlich zu funktionieren. Also ich hatte wahrgenommen, dass es einige Podcaster gab, die sich ein bisschen gewundert haben, dass sie im letzten Monat gesteigerte Einnahmen hatten oder zumindest erhöhte Flat Tactics. Wie sich das in den Einnahmen niedersteckt, ist ja nochmal eine ganz andere Sache. Und das ist jetzt von mir so ein bisschen geraten. Also ich habe natürlich jetzt keine belastbaren Zahlen an der Stelle, aber ich habe es halt auffällig häufig gelesen und habe es halt auch selber bemerkt. Und meiner Meinung nach liegt das an dieser letztes Mal schon erwähnten Instacast Cloud, die halt Platter jetzt dort integriert. Und naja, ich finde das total toll. Ich habe irgendwie sowieso nochmal durch meine Podcast-Liste durchgeschaut. Wir haben ja, die URL können wir auch nochmal reintun. Es gibt ja so ein großes Google-Spreadsheet unter tinyurl.com/podcast-clients. Wer schon immer mal einen guten Grund haben wollte, sich einen 70 zu 9 Bildschirm zu kaufen, da ist dieses spreadsheet genau das Richtige.
70 zu 9.
Ja, das läuft etwas breit. Also es gibt da sehr viele Spalten.
Das ist wie so eine Tapetenbanderohle oben kurz unter der Decke.
Man könnte da sicher auch eine gute Tapete draus machen. Das ist vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt das Kleidsamste, aber geht auf jeden Fall. Und da bin ich nochmal durchgegangen, was eigentlich alles so ein Podcast-Clients da draußen ist, was eben so eine ähnliche Funktionalität hat. Da gibt es ja noch mehr. Antennapod auf Android hat das, Volksempfänger, glaube ich, nicht mehr richtig weiterentwickelt hat das, aber auch. Und den dritten vergesse ich immer wieder. G-Poda hat das und eben Instacast in der Wolke. Also das ist so quasi das Ding. So, was kommt hier für ein Kommentar?
Oh, das ist ein wichtiger Kommentar im Chat. Der Kartoffelsalat-Gigstarter ist über 22.000 Dollar. Habt ihr das mitgekriegt mit dem Menschen, der sich den Kartoffelsalat kickstarten wollte für 10 Dollar? Und dann ging das ein bisschen weiter.
Ach, die haben ja jetzt geöffnet und machen keine Auslese mehr bei Kickstarter. Jetzt kann man ja da irgendwie alles proposen. Und worum geht's?
Na ja, wollte für 10 Dollar halt einen Kartoffelsalat machen für sich.
Wahrscheinlich wollte er beweisen, wie blöd es ist, dass man jetzt alles proposen kann und jetzt ist er selber Opfer.
Stretchgoals, 35.
Der Update ist ganz oft, du musst noch weiter scrollen.
250 Dollar, better mayonnaise. 300 Dollar, call a chef to get a better recipe. 350 Dollar, make way more potato salad and probably do a search recipe. Und jetzt geht's schon in die Nachrichten. A stretch goal ist 1000 Dollar. I do a live stream of the potato salad making. 1200, I pay someone to film a thank you video for all of my beggars. Und so weiter. 3000 Dollar, my kitchen is too small.
I will write down to party all in the internet for potato salad party.
Der ist jetzt auf über 22.000 Dollar.
Und jetzt ist ihm schon nichts mehr eingefallen, was er noch als stretch goal machen könnte. Oh Gott, er könnte gleich so die potato salad T-Shirt-Produktion irgendwie starten. Oh Mann ey, wenn das Internet Spaß hat, hat das Internet Spaß.
Das habe ich gestern gesehen, aber ich habe auch gedacht, das ist irgendwie, ja, warum kommt man da nicht selber drauf? Irgendwie, man möchte irgendwie was kochen und einem fehlen halt noch 10 Euro für Zutaten und so. Warum nicht Kickstarter? Das Problem ist, dass er jetzt halt irgendwie wahrscheinlich das nächste halbe Jahr mit seinem scheiß Kartoffelsalat beschäftigt ist, oder? Also, irgendwie das ganze, der will ja auch so Partyhütchen da.
Aber mal ganz ehrlich, also 20.000 Dollar für ein halbes Jahr ist jetzt aber auch nicht so schlecht.
Ja, vor allem, das ist ja noch nicht mal durch. Das ist ja irgendwie noch 25 Tage, läuft das ja noch.
Schön unter Risks and Challenges finde ich auch, it might not be that good. It's my first potato salad.
Das ist super.
Ja, da muss ein altes journalistisches Projekt lange für Kraut reportern.
Ja, da könnte man auch mal ein gutes halbes Jahr Potlaf ordentlich anschieben irgendwie. Hätte man mal auf die Sache mit dem Kartoffelsalat kommen sollen. Tja, das Ding ist jetzt durch. Million Dollar Homepage, sage ich nur. Das war auch so eine Idee. Ob das überhaupt noch unsere Zuhörer noch kennen? Ja, das war doch dieser Student, der irgendwie Geld brauchte.
Und dann, Roddy, du guckst so, als ob du das nicht kennst. Ja, wo man dann so Pixel kaufen konnte irgendwie.
Er hat einfach so eine Pixelwand aufgemacht, irgendwie 1000 mal 1000 Pixel und hat halt jeden Pixel für den Dollar verkauft. Und es waren eine Million Pixel, und es hat eine Million Dollar gegeben. Und dann hat er nicht nur diese Million Dollar bekommen, sondern lebt da teilweise heute noch davon, weil er irgendwie mittlerweile T-Shirts mit diesem Motiv verkauft. Völlig absurd. Viele von den Links gibt es auch gar nichts mehr. So Casinos haben sich da natürlich dick eingekauft. Aber es ist natürlich auch, sagen wir mal, eine sehr billige Methode gewesen, Teil der Internetkultur zu sein. Also unter der Maßgabe hätte man sich fast auch noch mal da eine Matrix kaufen müssen. So, wenn ich da irgendwie ein CAE-Logo reingepackt hätte, das hätte sicherlich seine Wirkung entfaltet. Aber naja, das ist halt vorbei, aber wäre halt auch teuer gewesen. Also so ein normales Webfuff-Icon sind dann immerhin schon mal 16 mal 16. Kommt schon einiges zusammen.
Ja, Roddi, jetzt hier nochmal eventuelle Swift-Nachträge. Was hatten wir jetzt heute? Kannst du noch mal kurz erklären?
Das Einzige, was wir noch nicht hatten, ist, dass sie dieses Array jetzt doch so umgebaut haben, dass es sinnvolle Dinge tut, wenn es eine Constant sein soll. Also ich fasse nochmal zusammen, bis zur Beta 2 war das so, dass wenn man in Swift eine Array-Variable, die konst war, gemacht hat, konnte man immer noch einzelne Elemente aus dem Array austauschen, aber man konnte es nicht vergrößern. Gleichzeitig war das nicht Constant Array so, dass du, wenn du A gleich B gemacht hast, A ist ein Array, B ist ein Array, du weißt das A zu und dann änderst du in B eins der Elemente, dann wird in A mit geändert, weil die irgendwie aufs Gleiche zeigen und wenn du dann aber ein Element hinzufügst, dann kopiert er doch das ganze Array. Also es war alles totales Chaos und das haben sie jetzt wohl hingebogen. Jetzt ist es so, wie man das erwarten würde, wenn es Konst ist, dann ist es Konst und wenn nicht, dann, und du weißt es zu, dann sind es zwei unterschiedliche Arrays und so. Also es ist irgendwie, da gibt es einen sehr länglichen Thread in der Developer Applecom Forum, der sehr lustig zu lesen ist, weil sie sich irgendwann nur noch im Kreis drehen. Die einen finden das nicht so schlimm und die anderen sagen, das kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein. Und irgendwie kommen sie nicht vom Fleck. Und irgendwann sagt dieser Chris Lettner, ja, ja, ist ja gut, wir haben es gehört, wir machen da was. Und jetzt haben sie was gemacht. Also das war jetzt das, was noch zu Swift-Nachtrag jetzt noch ist.
Na und dann, was haben wir vorhin noch gesehen, wenn man halt einen Ray deklariert, dann geht es jetzt auch ein bisschen anders, wenn man den Typ schon vorher festlegt. Da sind jetzt die Klammern, müssen jetzt um den Typ rum, rum sein. Vorher war das so komisch davor, was mir auch nicht gerade intuitiv vorkommt, ist jetzt immer noch nicht wirklich intuitiv, finde ich, aber ist schon mal ein Stück besser. Ich frage mich noch, was die runden Klammern an der Stelle sollen.
Die runden Klammern waren nur bei dir.
Wie, die waren nur bei mir? Du meinst, die brauchen wir eigentlich gar nicht?
Ich weiß nicht, warum du da runde Klammern gemacht hast.
Ohne wollte man nicht. Na gut, so viel zu Swift. Jedenfalls sieht man daran stark, was Apple ja schon angedeutet hat, dass die Runtime ist festgelegt, die Sprache nicht. Und klar, es ist jetzt noch in der Beta-Zeit, aber sie behalten sich auch vor, dass auch nächstes Jahr sie wieder was umgestellt haben oder in fünf Monaten. Also die Sprache soll weiterhin flexibel bleiben, so ein bisschen.
Also das, was Chris Lettner so immer wieder im Forum zum Besten gegeben hat, klang ganz so danach, dass in der Beta-Phase noch einiges passieren wird. Und wenn es dann die 1.0 gibt, dass sie es dann wohl nicht mehr so viel ändern.
Ja, das geht nicht ohne.
Also insofern.
Die müssen da hinten ran.
Whatever. Ja, keine Ahnung. Also das ist so. Mal abwarten, was mit dem Swift wird.
Das kommt schon.
Das kommt schon. Eigentlich ist ja auch eine ganz gute Sprache.
Du wirst ja noch zu haben für meinen Vorschlag, das mal auszuprobieren. Da reden wir gleich noch drüber.
Jetzt oute ich mich natürlich als nicht regelmäßiger Freak Show-Hörer, hab ja über die Verbindung zwischen Dylan und Swift geredet. Also es würde mich wundern, wenn nicht.
Sure, Batman. Ich hab versucht, es soweit dabei zu assoziieren, wie es geboten war.
Tim hat irgendwie Dylan erwähnt. Da ich Dylan nicht kenne, kann ich dann jetzt nicht so viel zu sagen.
Also die Ähnlichkeiten sind jetzt nicht so, also es gibt nicht so viele Ähnlichkeiten. Es gibt verschiedene Dinge, die ähnlich irgendwie angegangen werden und Dinge werden besser, aber es hat mit der alten Vision so nichts zu tun, weil es halt auf Basis einer ganz anderen Realität entstanden ist.
Stimmt schon.
Ich mag Dylan immer noch lieber.
Also ich habe das Gefühl, dass Swift schon aus C entstanden ist und dass sie bei C versucht haben, alles auszubauen, was irgendwie Probleme macht vom Pointer über halt diese komischen Case-Dinger, wo du automatisch durchfällst bis hin zu, weiß ich nicht, nimm irgendein C-Lehrbuch und guck dir an, was man alles nicht tun soll. Das haben sie alles ausgebaut. Und ansonsten versuchen sie zu Objective-C kompatibel zu sein und dabei ist Swift rausgekommen. Das merkt man einfach, dass es so entstanden ist.
Und sie haben sich sicherlich mal Ruby angeguckt.
Sie haben sich sicherlich Ruby angeguckt. Sie haben sich offensichtlich auch Erlang angeguckt. Sie haben sich sehr wahrscheinlich auch C-Sharp angeguckt und andere Programmiersprachen. Und Python und Haskell und C++.
Sie haben sich einfach alles angeschaut.
Insofern, aber ich glaube, der Haupteinfluss war sicherlich C. Ja, wie gesagt, mit dem KV hat alles ausgebaut, was bei C scheiße ist, was dann schon eine relativ andere Sprache ist. Aber ich hatte beim Durchlesen nicht das Gefühl, dass mir da irgendwas herangetragen wird, wo ich denke, so, hä, wieso machen sie das denn so? Sondern das ist schon alles so, wenn man C kann, dann fallen halt hier Semikolons weg und da fallen paar Runde-Klammern weg. Dafür musst du an anderer Stelle zwingend geschweifte Klammern machen und so weiter. Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist es jetzt nichts anderes. Und halt keine Pointer.
So.
Das war so mein Eindruck.
Wir werden sehen, was Leute damit hinbekommen. Ja, kurzer Nachtrag noch zu den Podcast-Client-Liste. Sollte es höher oder vielleicht was noch besser ist, dass es Developer von Podcast-Client geben, die sich entweder mit ihrem Client in dieser, von mir erwähnten Liste, noch nicht repräsentiert fühlen oder nicht angemessen repräsentiert fühlen, weil die Informationen dort unter Umständen falsch oder zumindest nicht mehr aktuell sind, dann erteile ich gerne einfach auf einfachen Zurufschreibzugriff. Ich wollte das jetzt, ob der Vandalismus-Problematik nicht so offen schreibbar haben, also wer da sozusagen mal freundlich fragt, den mir eine entsprechende Google-Count schickt, trage ich da gerne ein, um irgendwie einfach da so ein bisschen die Patenschaft für eine oder mehrere Clients zu nehmen. Und im Prinzip alles, was irgendwie Podcasts abspielt, also nicht nur die auf Mobile-Devices, sondern eben auch auf den Rechnern oder auch im Web, ist alles gern gesehen. So. Jetzt haben wir es, oder? Heute machen wir mal eine kurze Sendung. Wir haben ja noch um etwas Wichtiges vergessen.
Wenn du die Liste nicht mehr anzeigst. Wenn du die Liste nicht mehr anzeigst.
Na, das ist irgendwie alles so drauf. Ich könnte jetzt hier noch über Audio-Chats irgendwas erzählen, aber das ist eigentlich auch nur so ein bisschen Randthema. Ja, na ja, ich weiß nicht. Ich habe heute irgendwie gesehen, dass jetzt Skype auch noch irgendwie so ein Audio-Chat-Feature nachgerüstet hat und damit sind irgendwie...
Also Audio-Chat heißt dann immer nicht, wie telefonieren, sondern...
Du schreibst nicht Text, sondern du schreibst halt Audio.
Also wie Anrufbeantworter früher fast. Eigentlich bin ich ja froh, dass wir davon weg sind. Und jetzt führen sie das bei Streamer wieder ein. Ich weiß nicht, ich finde es nicht so cool.
Man muss es ja nicht benutzen, aber es gibt halt durchaus Situationen, wo das an sich ganz sinnvoll ist. Hast du denn meine Testnachrichten gehört?
Ja, habe ich doch geschrieben, dass ich es gehört habe.
Aber du fühltest dich nicht berufen, selber noch was beizutragen.
Nee, dann rufe ich an, wenn ich was sagen will. Oder quatsche ich dir auf die Box. Für jeden, der es noch nicht weiß, wenn man einem auf die Box quatschen will, obwohl er rangehen könnte, es gibt auch Nummern direkt zur Box durch. Man muss nicht beim Telefonieren.
Ich finde es ein bisschen albern, dass man da hinter so einem Telefon und drücken sie jetzt die 3 und die 4 und die 5 und die 6 und die 7 nur, damit ich mich da irgendwie durchhangen kann, wenn ich das auch einfach direkt mit Tab haben kann.
Ja, aber ich finde, da gibt es genug andere Baustellen in Streamer, die sie immer fixen könnten. Also weil Streamer kamen gerade mit diesem Voice-Chat da, wo sie was immer fixen könnten, was irgendwie sinniger wäre. Also ich weiß immer noch nicht, wenn mich Leute, die ich noch nicht kenne, wenn die mich anquatschen, in der Notification steht deren Nickname, den die sich gegeben haben, was natürlich alles Mögliche sein kann. Da steht ein Name. Und wenn ich dann aber in die Streamer-App reingehe und deren Nachricht sehe, da steht dann nur diese Hash-ID und ich weiß nicht, wer es gewesen ist und ich kann da keinen Zusammenhang feststellen und ich habe schon inzwischen mehrere User nur mit ID und weiß nicht mehr, wer wer ist. Das müssen die mal irgendwie fixen, das ist irgendwie blöd. Ja, die können den Nickname ja trotzdem anzeigen. Ist ja meine Entscheidung, ob ich der Sache nun traue oder nicht.
Also sie zeigen den Nickname an, aber nur wenn sich jemand auch ein Nickname gesetzt hat.
Ne, eben nicht. In der Notification, wenn mein Telefon gelockt ist, dann kommt da so von User Timme in deinem Fall, weil auch immer dein Nickname ist, wo da steht, von User Timme kam eine Nachricht. Angenommen, ich hab dich noch nicht drin in meinem Streamer. Und dann gehe ich rein, will die Nachricht sehen und dann steht nur deine komische ID da, weil er noch keine Connection zwischen deinem Nickname und der ID hat.
Also er zeigt dann nicht auch noch den Nickname an.
Ja genau, sondern nur bei der Notification. Also das heißt, es kommt schon so halb, aber nicht richtig. Und deswegen habe ich lauter User, wo ich nicht weiß, wer es ist, außer du kümmerst dich halt voll drum und fragst immer oder gleist irgendwie ab oder machst dir QR-Code, Voodoo.
Naja gut, ich wollte mal kurz auf diese Audio-Chats hinaus. Also Messages liefert es, also quasi iCloud liefert es jetzt nach. Streama hat es eingebaut, Skype hat es jetzt irgendwie eingebaut.
Warte langsam, bei Messages heißt es, kommt es jetzt in iOS 8.
Und die anderen haben das halt irgendwie eh alles schon. WhatsApp, WeChat. Ja, also all diese ganzen asiatischen Chats haben das alle.
Keine Ahnung, wenn die Hürde niedriger wird, mal eben irgendwie einen Satz ins Telefon zu sagen und das wie ein Chat loszuschicken, vielleicht wird es dann auch, könnte ich mir das vorstellen, dass ich das benutze, aber ich habe eigentlich irgendwie immer nicht so viel zu sagen. Ja, ich finde es auch immer schwierig, mit jemandem in Dialog zu treten, indem ich ihm irgendwas erzähle ins Nichts hinein.
Das ist bloß kein Podcast, das ist nichts für dich, Roddy.
Ach so.
Ja, das ist so wie Kurzpodcasting sozusagen.
So habe ich es noch nicht gesehen, vielleicht wird es dann besser. Hey, hier ist wieder...
Hey Roddy, du hast wahrscheinlich schon total darauf gewartet.
Schön, dass du wieder einschaltest.
Das ist eine Nachricht für dich. Und ich wünsche dir so einen wunderschönen Sonntag. Bis bald. Es war so schön von dir zu hören.
Schön, dass du wieder eingeschaltet hast.
Mal sehen, wann die ersten Werbelinger kommen.
Genau. Tipp auch das nächste Mal wieder auf den Play Button, wenn du das lustige kleine Emoji mit dem Stickefinger siehst. Nun gut, ich denke, wir haben es. Wir haben es.
Fehlen nicht noch die Standard-Themen?
Standard-Themen gibt es ja keine.
Ja, weiß ich nicht.
Es gab so schweren im Chat. ZFS, Bitcoin, Kalender.
Bitcoin 625 Dollar.
Ja, die neue ZFS-Version, die Journaling in der Blockchain macht und darauf basierend gibt es eine Kalender-Applikation.
Netter Versuch.
Vollkomm falsche Vorstellungen hier von dieser Sendung.
Aber von ZFS und OS X gibt es zumindest einen neuen Release-Kandidat, den man benutzen sollte, weil der beim Runterfahren des Rechners nicht hängen bleibt. Da sollte man...
Jetzt bist du aber voll in die Pfanne gegangen.
Wollte ich ja nur mal gesagt haben.
Genau, wir wollten das nur mal gesagt haben. So, vielen Dank Jens und vielen Dank Jan. Und vielen Dank für alle, die da draußen immer so fleißig zuhören, Shownotes schreiben, Flatter klicken und andere sinnvolle Kommentare machen, die Sendung Preisen weitererzählen oder irgendwie kritisieren.
Wir haben euch doch alle lieb.
Genau, wir haben euch alle lieb. Und deswegen schicken wir euch jetzt nach Hause ins Bettchen.
Ja, dürft heute mal früher schlafen gehen.
Und wir sagen Tschüss und bis bald.
Vor elf sogar, krasse Scheiße.
Vor elf, so sieht's aus.
Das sieht desnoterleben der F...